this is jocko podcast number 309 with
echo charles and me jacqueline good
evening erica good evening also joining
us tonight jp danielle good evening jp
good evening
so
i got very lucky in my career very lucky
in my career and was able to
learn a lot from being in the military
and a lot of
what the military taught me i was able
to learn because i was able to teach
i was you get put in positions
in the military where you're teaching
which is an awesome way to learn and it
starts and the seal team starts really
young
like the first time you go overseas
you're going to be teaching you're going
to be teaching some host nation
personnel
marksmanship or map and compass or
whatever
and so you're just kind of learning how
to teach
but then
where i really realized the power of
teaching and learning at the same time
was when i was in training sell at seal
team one when i got into training sell
at seal team one so i had done three
deployments three workouts three
deployments and i went to training solid
steel team one and when i got to say
training sell at sale team one i was
single no kids no cares
volunteered for every trip that there
was which means i got to teach
everything i taught every subject that
you could teach i taught land warfare
cqb what we used to call cqb when did
that change to cqc was it always cqc for
you
they would they would switch up between
ckb and cqc in sqt and i believe my
first platoon it was cqc yeah it was
they were really trying to hard like hey
it's now cqc and guys right
okay we had we had a new guy a free game
my second platoon we had this awesome
guy
and we had he had to write up like the
new guys had to write up their bullet
points for their evaluations
and he wrote
completed cqb training but he had it c
cubed like like three to the power of
three c cubed
c q b
and
every yeah c cubed b
he was totally serious like he thought
that's what it was called
so um and maybe that's why they had to
switch to
cqc to make up for the homes but look i
got to teach that i got to teach mount
or at least go on mount trips marops otb
i taught a diving course i taught a
freaking awesome diving course and this
is back in the day when the diving
course was five weeks long
and you did you'd take off your rig and
climb through pipes up into the piers
and stuff and then go do something then
come back and put your rig back on
spec recon top spec recon so i got to
teach everything i was very very lucky
and that's where i felt like i
really started to learn
and
what allows you to be able to learn so
much is you're detached
you are you are detached you're not part
of the platoon you're watching the
platoon so you are detached
and that's when you
if you pay attention
you realize that you can see so much
because you're detached and that really
brought it home for me and it's you know
it's what i wrote about leadership
strategy and tactics i kind of figured
that out on an oil rig
my first platoon about how to detach but
then when i realized as an instructor oh
you can see everything everything
everything
when you're in an elevated position or
when you take a step back
so
that was awesome and then from there i
got picked up for the officer program
assistant platoon commander platoon
commander tasking a commander went
through more workups more deployments
continue to learn assemble thoughts in
my head about
how to do things about how to run
missions about how to lead
and
those workups and those deployments
solidified a lot of ideas in my head
about combat leadership
and
the more i learned
as i was teaching the guys in my
platoons about stuff
and then the battle ramadi obviously put
those theories to the ultimate test
and
you know we're able to utilize those
those principles
for victory but
i'll tell you what it wasn't until i got
home took over
naval special warfare group one tradet
that's when the leadership principles
that we talk about all the time that's
when they got really crystallized
because at that time in that place
in my opinion
i think that was the best leadership
laboratory
and instructional
facility that has ever existed in the
world and look i know that is a crazy
crazy
big statement to make it's accurate but
the
what we were able to do
at that time
look we had a huge budget
the war was in full swing
because of our deployment
and because of our
combat experience in tasking a bruiser
being in sustained urban combat
man i was given
like the widest possible boundaries
to push the envelope and do whatever we
kind of wanted to do
and that's what we ended up with and
look the training that we went through
when we were in task and bruiser the
train the cadre that put us through
training was also awesome
so it was not like
it was not like this revolutionary
change
but we took it we did take it even
further we took and and even that
training you know when when i had roger
hayden on we came back from vietnam we
still do stuff so it's i'm not sitting
here saying that
that this training at that time was
better than anything else and it's
because of
us no what i'm saying is that the
training that you get to do is awesome
and when we were in that lucky moment in
time
because of the way the freaking planets
aligned it just was epic it was epic so
what we what we end up with is this we
have
we have
multiple arenas
multiple arenas of leadership challenges
to test
and train leadership capability
they're all different arenas you can go
to the two that i'm going to talk about
the most because they probably had the
most power was the land warfare arena
and then the mount or south arena and
this is another thing that they changed
at some point it used to be mount when i
was younger which was military
operations urban terrain and then it got
changed to south which is special
operations urban combat but whatever you
want to call it these two
these two arenas that we were allowed to
run these training missions
and we were had the opportunity to put
platoon after platoon after platoon
after platoon
through complex
dynamic reactive
intense realistic high pressure
scenarios where the difference between
success and failure came down to one
thing and one thing only it only came
down to one thing and that was
leadership
that was leadership it was 100
leadership if a if a platoon or a task
unit was successful it was because of
leadership and if the platoon or task
and it failed it was because of
leadership
because there's some constants
there's some variables and some
constants the constants are look you're
going to be in a stressful situation
it's going to be a complex mission
it's
going to be a
opposing force so the bad guys are going
to be highly capable they're also going
to be tightly controlled most of the
time sometimes sometimes my brothers
would get a little out of hand but most
of the time it's tightly controlled and
then you have a platoon or two platoons
of seals
now some people might think well you
know there's going to be a variation in
the seal platoons
and that is accurate there is going to
be
some level of variation of the skills in
a sealed platoon
but overall the variation of the troops
of the 14 or 16
shooters in that platoon overall when
you combine them all together you're
gonna have some smart guys
you're gonna have some dumb guys you're
gonna have some old guys you're gonna
have some new guys you're gonna have
some aggressive guys you're gonna have
some passive guys you're gonna have all
these different big guys small guys
you're gonna have all these different
guys and you take them all together and
you mix them up
and that platoon is going to fall within
the margin of error of a normal seal
platoon
that's what's going to happen
seals come in all different shapes and
sizes
and that's just the out the net outcome
that you get when you put them all
together is a seal platoon and they're
all
kind of pretty much the same thing look
there's a variance like i said there's a
variance but they're not
there's not one platoon that's filled
with idiots it just doesn't exist
with told everyone's a stud it doesn't
exist
occasionally we get these stacked
platoons occasionally and sometimes they
implode and sometimes they do good
because again you got the mixture
but
what would happen when a stacked platoon
just depends on how good the leader was
if the leader could contain those egos
that platoon could be great if he
couldn't it would fall apart
so because the platoon is kind of the
same
functional thing
within a within a margin of error
the only difference between success and
failure ends up being the
the platoon the platoon leadership
and it doesn't really even matter where
that platoon leadership is coming from
it doesn't really matter it took me it
probably took me um
one month to figure this out it took me
one month before i didn't care who the
leader was i didn't care if it was the
chief i didn't care if it was platoon
commander i didn't care if the if it was
the leading petty officer of the platoon
i didn't care if it was an e5 three e5s
that were just awesome and they could
make [__] happen
that that's enough leadership and
platoon that they can win all day
so you talk about when you were running
trading it took you a month to really
not care where that leadership came from
or
when you were in your first platoon
i would say
no when i was when i took over trade out
yes i was watching and at first i
thought hey here's the job for the oic
here's the job for the platoon chief
here's the job for the assistant platoon
commander here's the job for the lpl hey
these are the roles responsible i wrote
those roles and responsibilities out
and gave them to people and issued them
to people and they were like okay this
is cool
but then you'd realize you'd have a
platoon chief that didn't know what he
was doing or you'd have an oic that
didn't know what he was doing and so he
couldn't handle that job whatever that
job was but
if you had a horrible platoon chief but
the lpo was a badass wouldn't really
matter that guy would just cover for him
and and and make it happen and maybe the
maybe the chief is good at admin and so
he's kind of oh look man i'll take care
of the paperwork over here you know you
got to do your thing i mean it's not
like leif babin was relying heavily on
tony of fratty to handle the paperwork
for life right i bet you tony didn't
know how to turn on a computer right
because that's not what his skill set
was and it didn't matter one bit late's
doing paperwork his junior officer doing
paperwork tony's running tactics like
tony should be running tactics but that
can swap
yes that can swap you can end up with a
platoon commander who's just a stud and
has a good comprehension of tactics
and a platoon chief that doesn't really
get it
he's a good guy but he's not going to
add much from the tactical front but so
that's what it boils down to i didn't it
took me about a month to go look i don't
care as long as we have leaders in here
yeah i'm happy
and
so going through this training the
training that we had not only identified
who the leaders were
and then what their shortfalls were but
most important
it allowed us the opportunity
to teach them how to lead that was the
most important thing was that it allowed
us the opportunity
to teach them how to lead and and the
lessons that you get learned in these
dynamic environments when you feel them
you ever heard that thing he who suffers
remembers yes so it's i think i think i
quite frankly got that in a fortune
cookie at some point in my life i don't
want to
tell you i got it from sun tzu
or musashi i'm pretty sure there's also
some bible verses around that as well
but okay yeah i didn't get it from any
of those i think i legitimately got him
from a fortune cookie he who suffers
remembers and that's kind of what
happens you go through this training and
it's hard not so much like oh it's
physically hard but all of a sudden you
look around and everyone's no one knows
what's happening and you go i'm supposed
to be in charge of this i'm horrible
yeah and you i don't want to make this
mistake again and
and that's what's incredibly um
important the one of the key components
of this training all of it it was
there's three major components to it
it was humbling
and it was humbling
and if you couldn't
if you couldn't
if you approached that training in a
humble way guys would just do awesome
and we had
freaking studs
just total
studs legendary seals come through that
training legendary badass seals come
through that training and totally humble
and be like yup we screwed that up and
just be awesome and they would turn
their platoon around and just kick ass
and it would be unbelievable
and then you'd have other guys come
through whether they had a lot of
experience or not or whatever their
background was where they didn't have
any humility and it would just eat them
alive it would be horrible to watch
and you couldn't really help them it was
painful you couldn't it was painful
but having this training and running
this training and seeing the the the
literal transformation of minds
to see
you could see i it's a light switch
sometimes it's a light switch for some
guys some guys it's a little bit more
like a dimmer switch that's getting
turned on
but to see them go from not
understanding how to lead to fully being
capable of how to lead
was incredible and we would see it
because
in the beginning of let's say the the
field training exercise
time of land warfare or of
urban training
the first couple days you know it's four
or five days maybe six days of training
the first few days the platoon is
getting annihilated
annihilated
and as they start to learn the lessons
as they start to implement the lessons
all of a sudden you fast forward to the
last day and the the opposing force the
bad guys can't get anything done they're
getting locked down they're getting shot
they're getting pinned down they're
getting maneuvered on because
the leaders learn how to lead
and and that's why you know eventually
we took this this training and wanted to
duplicate it for the business world
so we could get these same tools
to help organizations and and help
leaders
learn to lead
which is the most important skill in the
world bar none
but
jp you ended up taking that you ended up
coming over here we'll get into that but
let's talk about when you came home
from deployment to ramadi and you
immediately went to buds for a short
glorious and uh uh crazies
no but just fill us in it's actually
kind of funny i was talking to a couple
young teen guys
the other day and
i was explaining to them that when you
came home
you went and they were like asking about
you and i said you know you know he came
home he he went to buds and and they
were like oh and i go oh it was no it
was bad i mean it was so bad it just
it's embarrassing really you know it's
embarrassing because
you
we just came back from ramadi
and
you know i'm i'm looking at all these
guys going through training
comparing them to mikey and mark and
ryan and cowie and all the guys in our
task unit that were injured right and
that stayed in the fight i mean we had
multiple guys get wounded on that
deployment that stayed on deployment
and then those marines and those
soldiers that we worked with were some
of the bravest humans we'd ever been
alongside and so i'm i'm
mad that i'm not overseas because i
wanted to still be over there
and i got pulled from my platoon and
that was what was the worst part is
because i had shoulder surgery ended up
with some temporary nerve damage where i
would just drop something well you can't
be in an active platoon when that
happens and so
i get pulled from the platoon what phase
did they put you in
indock so before they even start first
phase
so
how old were you how old were you
like 23 i was still 23.
yep i remember yeah um i was i was 23
when i was at buds um no i'm sorry i was
i turned 24 and then i went there
because i had the surgery and the like
so there's a little more time yes i mean
not much i mean come back from ramadi
yeah and then
uh you know we started the work up i was
i went to you know i was going to school
we started the work up
and had to have surgery
issues with the surgery
you know there i was at the i was still
at team three for a while
and you know because stone was my task
unit commander and i i mean i was just
super fired up i could i was so excited
to go back and
i think we knew we were going to be
going to
solder city at the time and so
anyway so i get pulled i go to buds um
and i am just
an absolute train wreck right there i'm
comparing
all these like i said all these guys to
mark and mikey and ryan and callie and
like right so what are you supposed to
be doing in indock you're supposed to be
just pt'ing them and kind of like you're
preparing them for first face right so
you're not supposed to be beating the
[__] out of them no
i don't comprehend that
well when i got pulled aside and they
said hey jp this isn't first phase
you're not supposed to have this many
guys quit
yeah i was how long did you last it
wasn't that long it wasn't long thank
god like for the community because
i mean so like i said what would you
what was your favorite way to torture uh
students because i was thinking about
this too so you get this leadership
laboratory that we had where what we
figured out
was what exactly what
where to apply pressure where to relieve
pressure on these leaders to force them
to
start to understand how to lead
and how if they didn't understand it how
they were going to break but i was
thinking about it if you're a buds
instructor what you learn is how to get
into people's heads and apply pressure
to make them break yeah
yeah so
one of the um i'll give you two examples
of some stuff like one that was probably
like the worst that i did that i
definitely should know is there a
statute of limitations on this stuff are
we clear
i'm sure
i'm sure the leadership knew about this
eventually
um it was at the end of the day
and they were leaving the pool deck and
all the other instructors had gone
and that's a mistake right there
all the instructors and i was by myself
and
there's a lot of other stuff that was
going on in my life so i literally had
no life outside of this so i didn't have
to go back home i actually got a room at
the barracks so i didn't even have to
leave i was just sleeping in the
barracks there like just
making these students life absolute hell
i mean i was
it wasn't cool what i was doing like i
know that i'm very apologetic and i feel
really bad now that i'm older and a
little more mature
but um one of the times i like i took
like they were trying to leave the pool
deck and someone did something stupid
like you know a basic student thing like
it should have been like 20 push-ups or
you know make them like jump in the pool
with their gear and come back out and go
but i was like nope i brought them down
to the pool deck like so you know the
observation
like deck down below oh where you're
underwater yeah you're under the pool
and underwater and you can see the
people you can see the pool and it's
dark down there and nobody knows you're
down there and nobody can hear that
you're down there so i brought them down
there and closed the gate to the
compound to where it looked like
everybody was gone
and beat them down there for i it was
over an hour minimum just like
just doing different like flutter kicks
like the
uh belly back feet drills where they're
just rolling
all right you guys can't seem to get in
sync and then just continue going
through it
um
so anyways that happened and then
another time um i was just walking by
the barracks and looked in one of the
windows of the the barracks and it was
unlocked and i'm like oh cool climbed in
their window into their room was jungle
inspection opened up the fridge and
there was like two 18 packs of beer
i was like
okay so i
emptied every beer into the room and
then went and found the class oic
brought the oic oic in there
and the kids that were in there were
underage oh i was like
how do you guys want to handle this
like i wasn't going to try to get these
kids in trouble for underage drinking
because i'm not going to be a hypocrite
when i went through buzz i was 18 and
guess what i would do on the weekends i
would go have some beers with my friends
like i know it happens
and if you drink underage i know you're
not i'm not condemning this but if
you're trying to go into the field teams
and you're going to have a beer underage
like for me that's not something that's
like oh we can't trust that guy
you know in our especially in our
community i know it's not right i'm not
saying it's right yeah well yeah and
nowadays
you're done yeah you're done 100
and zero tolerance is an actual real
thing now and so
there's i wasn't gonna i was at least at
least
stable enough to know that i'm not going
to ruin somebody's career over this that
that that's not fair
because that happened to my brother my
brother was in a school
with a contract to go to buds he would
have been like two
no four buds classes behind me and he
was training in a school
got injured and so he got rolled back to
where he couldn't class up had surgery
came back
most kids in a school right they go off
base they have some drinks he came back
came back they had been drinking
turns out like was was he underage yeah
he was underage he was 18 at the time
and um he got in trouble and they were
like who was with you drinking he's like
it was me i was the only one drinking
they're like who was with you he wasn't
gonna say anything he was gonna rat on
the guys at all
i didn't know about this until recently
until a guy who was in the teams at a
different command running training told
me he's like the reason why i'm still in
the navy and here is because of your
brother i'm like
what
he goes yeah your brother covered for
all of us my brother didn't like was
like nope it's just me so my brother
ended up getting admin stepped out of
the navy for underage drinking dang he
lost his contract to go to buds and
everything yeah so
i knew that happened to corey and
corey's a freaking stud you met my
brother he's super smart like he's one
of the smartest guys i know he's a he
was a physical stud still is and just
i wasn't gonna be yeah i wasn't gonna do
that
so i gave
the oic aoic an option and
we secured them for the weekend and it
was just uniform inspections
about every 90 minutes
and um
yeah a crappy thing i didn't know it
until i came to check out muster001 with
y'all met jamie cochran
and she's like yeah you might know my
husband he was in the teams and she was
like his name's flynn i was like i don't
know i don't know fine
and then later on i see him i'm like
what's up bro and he like gives me bro
hug and i was like what are you doing
here's like my wife jamie she's like you
guys know each other
and he goes yeah as instructor janelle
i'm like cochran that's how we knew each
other i didn't know
and flynn tells jamie he's like yeah jp
is the reason why i missed our wedding i
was like
what well that weekend that i secured
him
he was oic
he didn't tell me he was supposed to be
flying up to seattle to have a wedding
him and jamie got married
but then they were having a big official
official they did the official one but
now they're doing a party official doing
a party for all the family well he i
secured him that weekend
and so he missed out on that and i was
like oh this is great so this is my
first introduction to jamie five years
ago
and yeah so
yeah when i was an instructor at buds i
was
i was thinking about when i went through
buds what some of the instructors used
to do and some of those instructors were
evil evil yeah you know the you know
about the
the red circle right the red circle and
dive phase where you'd have to bear
crawl with all your gear on until there
was blood in a circle from guys like
hands and feet getting raw and just
crazy stuff like now
there's i'd be surprised if some of that
stuff still went on
yeah well they may have other ways hey
they have other ways and there should be
other ways to there's thin the herd and
hold that there's uh that training is
freaking hard
right now oh yeah it's it's probably
harder i guarantee you it's probably
harder
and just in a different way but yeah
they're not like like i mean i had a
instructor that got in trouble because
he would test the sharpness of the
knives by cutting people's freaking
palms
right like that's what is happening
that's crazy yeah he got in trouble for
it
uh we had an instructor that got in
trouble because we had to do push-ups on
the back of our hands
with twin 72s on our backs and yeah yeah
i mean you're just hell hey why don't
just why don't you just hit people's
freaking hand with a ball peen hammer
just to call it good well one time i
came back to the court like i said i
lived on base
i mean i had a room i lived with derek
benson
who is my homeboy for since like we
checked in the teams together and just
really you know another good team guy
from northern california
he had an awesome house we lived i lived
there
but i was so obsessed when i was a buzz
instructor
and i saw i was living on base like i
said i had the room in the barracks and
i was staying there and i i caught um
a guy at the quarter deck watch asleep
and i just beat his boots off man for
like three hours straight
and then i made him call the oic who
lived down in ib
he had to get dressed he came in i was
like where's lpo so he calls him he
lives out in town as well and it was
just a beat session until all of them
got there and i explained
what happens when guys fall asleep on
watch overseas and i told them about the
stories that we'd hear about marines
being murdered because somebody fell
asleep when they're in in a building
right or soldiers that same thing had
happened to him it's the same thing that
we would talk about when we were in
ramadi
we weren't going to let anybody else be
in charge of standing watch unless you
were a team guy because we knew
we couldn't like we weren't going to let
the iraqi soldiers like hey you stand
watch okay cool
just gonna fall asleep like leaning on
his rifle and his toe on the trigger
like it's just crazy so
yeah i was i was wound real tight
what was the straw that broke the
camel's back
that
what was it was did anything specific
happen where they're like all right we
gotta get this guy out of here
it was just constant like i i didn't so
the problem is
because i remember i i know they called
you specifically yeah they were like hey
basically you need to come get your boy
yeah because i feel like a straight ramp
over there i was separately assigned
i was temporarily assigned duty to the
command
so i was getting ready to actually i was
probably gonna get in trouble because i
i didn't well
the horrible thing is like i didn't
respect the chief that was in charge of
the training he was a piece of [__] team
guy
he just didn't represent the teams and
well in anything with his life his
reputation the teams you know we're
we're instructors
at buds and he is grossly overweight i'm
just like and it wasn't because of an
injury there are some guys that have
injuries that go there that's one thing
no it was his actual lack of discipline
just it was i had zero respect for him
and so he was the one that was like
pulling me aside and trying to like hey
you shouldn't be doing this and i'm like
you're going harder yes yeah i'm like
okay yep roger that
you know that that
that feeling of
this is the same type of feeling that i
would have so when we'd be out at mount
or something like this when when i was
running it
and i'd see like a guy standing in the
middle of the street and i would get
like a knot in my stomach i would i
would start to sweat and i would get so
kind of so emotional about like hey
this guy's going to get [__] killed
yeah and and i can't imagine like here
you are
you're having the same feeling but oh
this guy's falling asleep on watch this
is a night this is i can't allow this
guy in the teams like that level of
commitment and emotional commitment to
wanting to make sure that the guys that
are gonna make it to the teams are the
best freaking guys and that was me i was
trying to make sure that these guys were
ready and it was a very
it was an emotional thing it was an
emotional thing yeah i was
a hundred percent like i my
my marriage at the time
was falling apart
and i was okay with that because i was
more concerned about the teams
and in hindsight like okay cool she was
a good person we weren't good together
like i'm very thankful that that didn't
work out because
of my family that i have now i'm very
thankful
but i was so just in the t like that's
all that mattered was the teams the
teams the teams and
i
yeah i just i was like you just said i
was just emotionally involved and
connected all the time
you know i i saw guys that i put through
training and they'd come back through
training later on like the training we
ran and then i see them out in the teams
and i'm always like hey man i'm sorry
they're like bro
you cared about the teams like we're
good with that and it's funny because
the guys that made through training that
turned out to be good team guys
it
bothered none of them
not one of those guys ever were like
yeah that kind of sucked they were just
like
bro you were in the game like you just
came back from so they they understood
it
yeah and what you just said is you know
the the leadership thing right you're so
emotionally invested in getting these
guys trained and developed and when you
took over training
you saw the void of the leadership
training our tactics are ridiculous the
amount of money and the high level
training that we have when it comes to
all the like the tactical stuff that we
do is is awesome can we make it better
all the time yes we're always trying to
make it better
but we actually didn't have any actual
leadership development and it showed in
all other areas of the teams and i know
i've talked with you a lot about this is
i was very aware
that i was young and immature and not
going to be a good leader i knew that
and i wanted i craved that leadership
development and training
and i saw that outside of the military
like i was reading business books and
personal development books because i
knew i just needed that and the teams
didn't have that until you i always
thought it's crazies you didn't go to
like
leadership development training until
you're in e7 e89 i'm like crazy they
need it as an e3 e4 e5 e6 where there's
a large
portion of our community is at that rank
and they have a large amount of
interaction with other forces out there
they need professional development and
leadership development and it wasn't
until you took over trade that we didn't
have that yeah the it was really strange
the way the teams used to be and you it
was all ojt and you were gonna learn you
learned your leadership skills from
whoever your chief was whoever your
platoon commander was you know your
platoon commander is probably gonna
learn from his chief
but
which is awesome
if you have an awesome chief
and if you don't have an awesome chief
you don't and and sometimes you'd get it
like a platoon chief coming through our
training
and you'd he'd have issues
and you could pull the thread and see
like who he did his lpo for who he you
could kind of figure out what his
background was because
you would just get this string of people
that just weren't really the best
leaders they were
you know people that led through their
rank or people that didn't understand
tactics and so you end up with you had a
very wide variety of
a wide span of skills that these leaders
had
and there was no one there was no one
teaching them all right here's here's
what you need to do as a leader so when
i put together that freaking leadership
brief it was like okay
it was
i was very lucky to be able to do that
and that's what
that that's what was cool that was
awesome for me and you know it's funny
because
i never said to like
i never said to leif or to seth like hey
here's the four laws coming i didn't say
that to him what we did yeah i was like
hey dude hey you need to you put your
machine gunners out if you're going
across the road why you need a cover for
them you need a cover for okay that's
cover move like dude your plan is
freaking way crazy complicated so
those guys got it over time
you know um just through repetitive
interactions
of saying dude what are you doing trying
to get a head count right now you're
freaking getting shot at what are you
doing like stoner would be like roger
you know like no handle that [__]
and so
all those i had a bunch of things in my
head but when i got to trade at that's
when i was like oh i well that was a
that was the huge eye opener for me i
had
leif and seth and the and the officers
and be able to say like hey we're gonna
do that iteration again we're going to
be here for a month at land warfare i'm
going to get to teach you this little
things make little adjustments but when
i took over trade it was like oh i'm
going to see this platoon for a week
here and a week there in a week there
and i need to dump them all this
information as quickly as i can
in a way that they can understand it
so that's why the very first thing that
i went the very first training evolution
i went on went back and wrote down those
four laws of combat
it goes on one of the things that we
talk about and we teach at ashland front
is when you put somebody in charge of
training or in charge of just anything
it changes the way they think and
naturally so
you had been thinking this way for your
whole career
but
it wasn't until you were in charge of
trade it that you were actually more
mindful of
oh
yeah and then you just sat and you
thought about it and it's it's one of
the things that we do obviously in the
field training exercises is everyone
gets rotated through different positions
of leadership but you started really
implementing it
at trade it where every or actually no
i'm sorry in our task unit where
everybody was going to be in charge of
something oh yeah yeah and it was like
hey biggles you're in you're the tasking
commander for this run what
jp you're going to be the acting platoon
chief
what
but once we were in those positions of
leadership it forced us to think
differently and then once we had that
new
you know thought process it changed the
way we operated going forward and that's
why
training is so critical to success yeah
i was thinking if you were right or not
and
you were right because i was thinking if
i would have just done another task unit
i would have done the same exact same
thing i wouldn't have i would have
trained the guys the same way and i
would have trained the guys through
more of an indirect method of like hey
let's do that again oh you need to make
sure you're covering hey make that's a
little bit comp i would have done it the
same way i did it with leif and seth and
the rest of the guys like hey this is
what you're going to learn over the next
year i wouldn't have said oh this stuff
needed to be distilled down here's the
way it's going to be and i need to kind
of get this
formula that people can utilize
immediately i would have done that if it
wasn't if i hadn't been put into
training so
yeah you're right you're right
i think
i you know whatever i heard like a
little rumor or whatever i don't know
who called me but someone you know
basically it was like colonel troutman
was getting the call like you need to
come get your boy
because because you're gonna have to
give the reference so people understand
what you're talking about oh rambo rambo
colonel troutman you know rambo's out in
the woods um uh you know killing
civilians killing friendly civilians
there are no friendly civilians but he's
out there doing that
and they have to go get or colonel
troutman shows up to get him out and
freaking
get him back under control and i got
some kind of a call like that and it's
so funny because
everybody knew 100
that i was 100
going to absolutely take you bring you
shield you and there was going to be no
beef about this whatsoever no one even
made like any reference to anything
other than this is 100 good to go jocko
you you know jp
you're not really fitting here too well
come get your boy
all good it wasn't like hey this guy no
one even no one even would say a
negative thing about you they were just
saying like hey
you you might he might be a little
better if he goes back working for you
again i'm like jack 100
i don't know who it was i want to say
i mean through that was so long ago but
i feel like it was z
i feel like some you know it might have
been bobby so
bobby was there uh-huh
so he pulled me aside a few times and i
had always had tremendous amount of
respect for him yeah yeah which was
awesome yeah he's a stud guy i always
looked up to and there's a few times
like he pulled me aside and i was just
like so well and tight
but this shitty chief that was in charge
of us just completely
like even though bobby was like kind of
ran me back and i was like okay yeah and
then
this guy i was like nope gotta go harder
and tell i mean he might have i don't
know i don't know but he might have
reached out to z z got a hold of you
either way it was i was probably gonna
get in trouble
and um they were like oh he's tid he's
where is he attack oh he's still at team
three but he can't go back there
jocko bring him to trade and i remember
when i went there because that day i
checked in there i went how to talk with
you you introdu you introduced me to a
few guys
and it was i was like this is where i
need to be and i i still i know we'll
get in this a little bit more i there
was i was excited to be there fulfilled
to be there
but
i didn't fully grasp well yeah it took
you a little bit they took you you still
wanted to be overseas shooting people
yeah which is a big um gaping hole in
your heart when you're not overseas
shooting people and instead you're back
in america which is just boring and
miserable and you didn't want to be
doing that whether it was instructing
in doc students or at trade
but yeah we just had to make a little
connection between
you know you being at trade at and by
the way
making sure our guys are the best
trained in the world yeah and that's the
conversation we had yep um and then you
went right you went you went right into
salk did you go right into salk
yes
yep it was sal and ckc i was i was
running i was in
in both
and then
salk is when uh i think i was there for
a year and then i became the lpo of salk
so let's talk a little bit about um
salk and what's interesting so this is
again this is urban training we have a
few urban training sites that we would
use
we would set they were very realistic
very realistic training
we had set designers come out to design
things to make them look like they were
little villages in iraq or afghanistan
um we would have
speakers with noise simulations coming
over them
i remember we had we set burn we set
tires on fire and because i remember the
first time i went into ramadi at night
the moose had set fire set tires on fire
all the place totally screwing up your
night vision and i was like damn these
these dudes are next level they're smart
yep and i was like okay and sure enough
we would have the fires going we'd have
the noise simulators going so you hear
like urban noises
and then you do then comes the call to
prayer
and
it's
very realistic when i would put down my
nods because i'm an instructor whenever
i'm in my instructor mode when i would
put down my nods and start walking i
would 100 percent feel like
not overseas i was i was in iraq
so the realism
is
legit
totally legit
um
the interesting thing is that coming
into the training we would tell them
exactly what they needed to do to win
and this is what this is why this is
what's interesting so going to cqc
when i go out and watch cqc you'd have
some instructors that would like to
talk a lot
and you'd have another instructor that
or another group of instructors where
they do a little bit more action a
little less talk a little more do
and
you take those two groups like there'd
be one platoon with a talking instructor
and one platoon with an action
instructor and so the talking instructor
he's sitting there telling stories and
talking about this and giving all these
details and talking through it again and
hey watch this and watch me do this and
let me explain to you this and talk and
talk and talk and talk
and then there'd be another guy like hey
here's the basic here's the fundamentals
all right start doing it
and almost
well it's guaranteed that the platoon
that started doing it is going to learn
it quicker the platoon that just gets to
hear about it
it's not going to
it's not going to land now look you need
some level of instruction somebody needs
to tell you like this is what we're
doing this is how we do it you can't
just go blind obviously
but
what's interesting is we would tell the
guys hey
here's what you need to do to win
cover move simple prioritize and execute
decentralized command you need to do
that
if you don't cover and move out here
you're going to get shot up
if you don't have a simple plan it's
going to be insane
and we're going to have a bunch of
problems you need to prioritize next
year
by the way
you need to use decentralized command
because things will be happening that
not one person can control
you need to detach take a step back like
we would tell them these things we would
tell them
but
they would understand it but then you
got to go and do it you got to go and
poop get put in to those situations
i mean i'm just writing so much down
like since i started talking i just want
to hit all these points but um what
you're just talking about goes along
with i remember when i was at trade at
one of my chiefs told me as an
instructor he's like hey
we have to teach these guys how to think
not what to think because the
battlefield is very dynamic and these
guys need to be able to think on their
own
and it wasn't until we actually had them
out there doing it
it doesn't matter you can give a
scenario all day long you can tell
stories but until somebody's actually
putting their hands on it
it doesn't matter i you know i teach
shooting on the side and i can talk
about it all day long but until i have
somebody actually loading rounds into a
magazine and then
locking the slide to the rear and be
like oh that little butt yeah that's how
you lock the slide to the rear and i can
talk about all day long but if they've
never done it to watch somebody
fumble over the most basic thing that i
think is just the most basic thing ever
but if they've never shot before it's
actually a real big deal locking slide
to rear putting a loaded magazine into a
gun releasing the slide making sure
round's chambered these are things that
you and i do without even thinking no
thought whatsoever no thought what's up
i can hear the slide go forward and know
if a round is chambered or not whether
it was that magazine seated all the way
was it not did a round actually get
chambered and i've done that before i'm
like there's nothing in there and i
checked the magazine it wasn't fully
seated check the chain yep no round in
there
because we've done it hundreds of
thousands of times someone who's never
done it they actually have to do it
before they can
feel it and when people feel it
then that's what that's when it it comes
home like you were saying earlier like
when you when you make a mistake and you
feel that mistake when um
the cool thing about the ftx program is
i've been able to build a team you know
and cody's been on full time with us for
she's almost over three years now
we just got carlos mendes on on board
full-time or
i mean
you know all these guys that have on the
team are studs you know callie danny
and
we do what we teach right and so now my
team is doing all the classes all the
intros in the morning so i can be
detached i listen i observe i come in
with my points when i need them and one
of the things carlos always says that i
always said that cody always says that
you guys always say is hey when you make
a mistake where it costs you something
you feel that and you remember it
and it's just that's the power of
training is when you can feel a mistake
you'll remember that mistake
there's something
when you said you got to do it right
it's so strange
the experience that you can watch people
have
as they get wrapped up and absorbed and
overwhelmed by the mayhem and this
happens when you run your ftx's when i'm
out there i'll watch people go insane
they're totally they're having an out of
body experience like an out of mind
experience it's crazy to watch
and sometimes they don't even understand
it
i remember when we first started getting
video cameras and we started videoing
training this was like the first time i
would say i videoed training was maybe
in the late
1990s hey let's watch our room entries
and see what they look like
and occasionally you'd get a guy that
would just do something so insane
and they wouldn't even understand that
they had done it they would they
wouldn't understand that they had done
it and you'd have to say look at the
video watch watch what you just did we'd
be like hey you backed out of that room
i didn't back out of the room no way
okay watch this there you are literally
backing out of the room right you didn't
even understand that you did it
i remember i used to have my little
audio voice recorder
so i used to carry a little audio voice
recorder echo charles yes sir and the
reason because at during these nighttime
ftx's there's all this stuff happening
and you can't write notes so i would
just most of the time i'd just be saying
oh they pulled a guy off the flank over
there that guy's left by himself that
this is gonna go bad i would be making
notes to myself and then i'd come back
and be like hey you guys left that guy
on the flank that's how he got left
behind so i would make notes myself but
then sometimes i would use it to capture
the audio of what was actually occurring
of people losing their minds of people
yelling screaming
giving crazy orders not under like i
would record conversations that were
mutually unintelligible between two
people where two people were talking to
each other and neither one of them it
made you could play it it would be a
senseless conversation that made no
sense whatsoever they're talking about
two totally different things like one
guy's like we need to get back over
there another guy's like yeah we do but
one person is talking about back over
there behind the building the other
person's talking about back over there
across the street they're talking about
two totally different things and you i
would record them
and and then play it back for them and
they'd realize
how absorbed and how you get into this
mode where your world is shrinking
you're you're getting target fixation
you're it's the opposite of detachment
you're doing the opposite thing you're
just getting fixated on what's right in
front of you and it'd be a total
disaster
but what's good is
when they'd hear that video or they hear
that audio and you'd see the look on
their face like damn dude i suck
i suck i sounded like an idiot i sounded
like a complete idiot and then that
would be a way to kind of crack the ego
open and crack the mind open and for
them to be like dude what are you saying
i need to do yep here's what you need to
do take a step back man when this stuff
starts getting crazy when people start
yelling if you're yelling you're the
platoon commander if you're yelling and
screaming this is not a good indication
so as soon as you start raising your
voice think to yourself why am i raising
my voice right now what it what is
happening i'm not saying you never have
to raise your voice because sometimes
you do sometimes you gotta you gotta get
control things but if that's what's
happening
you know something's wrong
so guys would
that's what would start to kind of get
their minds open sometimes where
they would start to realize like oh
i'm not as good as i thought i was
and i just held a freaking out of body
experience and i think i might be an
idiot
that that's what makes the field
training exercise remember when we run
an eschew on front
that's what makes it the most impactful
form of training that we have at echelon
front because
you're feeling it like you said that
late this isn't just me saying because
it's my
my program right it's
because it's the truth like you actually
feel it you come back from a run and
you're humbled and you're sitting there
and the first thing we do is we debrief
that run all right what was your key
takeaways and we're always very clear
remember we don't care about the tactics
we're not here to teach you tactics i
don't if you were supposed to come up on
the east side you went to the west side
it doesn't matter
what did what was your takeaway that
applies to business or your personal
life and so people are like you said
that you just cracked it open they feel
that it's humbling um we had a guy
you're talking about like people just
saying crazy stuff
we've we've heard this one multiple
times it'll be like squad one line up on
the left squad two line up on the left
yeah and people are like look around why
and they're like why is nobody moving
they don't realize they said that
we were running one a few weeks ago up
in michigan
and it's one of our scenarios where i'm
not going to give it out but anyways
it's a stressful situation and also we
we changed something on them it's a
prioritizing execute run and the guy's
sitting there and they come up with a
plan and somebody asks a question he's
like it's the plan that they came up
with we're gonna do
he was quoting as if it was somebody
else's plan but it was his plan that he
just came that he's telling the team to
go but he's so overwhelmed and i
remember i was watching him and he like
just drops the laser tagger to the side
his hands to his side and takes a step
back and looks around and goes
we're going to do their plan
oh i'm writing this one down yep
have you ever heard that jason gardner
story jason gardner they get done
they're at cqc they're like out out
right here in socal just in our little
kill house they do a run
and they're standing around debriefing
and one of the officers cracks off
around as they're standing there
debriefing it goes between like a guy's
legs
and the guy the guy looks up and he he
goes
he was decocking it meaning he's talking
about himself in the third person as if
that's the exact same thing dude like
you're when you start referring to
what's happening as if it's someone else
in a bad way this is not a good sign
i stole your uh your voice recorder
trick for when i got out and i was doing
sales and i'd be driving you know i
would start off cold calling and then
i'd just go to appointments and i was
more efficient on the road but i would
try to hit as many people as a day and i
get done with a run well i had to take
notes on the conversation i just had so
i could follow up with the right
contract and everything else like that
but
i also couldn't sit in a parking lot for
15-20 minutes because i had other
clients i had that anxiety that i needed
to go go
well i was also commission based only so
i needed to get out there and so i i
bought a a recorder and i'd get done
with the meeting as soon as i walked out
of their doors to my rental car i'd
start debriefing myself on that meeting
as i'm driving in the next one stop and
then i would do that and then at the end
of the night i would listen to all those
notes that i had for each one generate
the emails contracts whatever get them
sent out and it was i mean i stole that
from you from tradex it was efficient
i have some of those recordings i sent i
sent a group text with some of those
recordings some some team guy because
team guys used to record me debriefing
now it wasn't me wasn't those things i
do have some of those things too still
some of them just out in the field like
like hey what's going on right now i
have no idea
we're all gonna die uh
so some of the problems that we would
throw
at the teams obviously giving them down
men was was a big one
and giving them civilians to deal with
putting them in an ied field we'd build
little simulated ieds so things are
blowing up
[Music]
kinda
they would end up with split forces for
whatever reason whether we set up a
target where it made sense for them to
split forces
or we would just drive some situation
that would make them split their forces
give them target and then change the
target so they've got like updating
intel
and so that there's a bunch of problems
right there and we haven't even
mentioned that there could be an enemy
shooting at you right so those problems
down man civilians ied field split
forces changing targets you haven't even
encountered the enemy yet right so so
you know it's gonna get wild
and then once we start bringing the
enemy on
and that's when you start to get into
you know barricaded shooters and
you're taking massive casualties
and hostage situations you know we would
capture the one of the seals we get left
behind we'd capture them
i mean i used to give 72 hour liberty if
you could get a seal like if jay i'd be
like all right boys you bring me back a
body you bring me back a live one you
got 72 hour liberty
remember i brought brought you back a
few and one of the times i actually took
the the guy's camis and gear off of him
oh yeah and then put all the clothes
back on and then joined back in with the
group and just started murdering
everybody from the inside got into one
of their humvees drove off came back was
like shooting them with their own 50 cow
and they're like
like what does our guy do like because i
was wearing the kit and the camis and it
i looked like i was one of those guys
yep
yep and that that's the kind of mayhem
that would go down well it didn't help
when you're like jp activated
done eyes rolled back like a shark
what can i get away with
oh man
uh
and here's here's the deal like i said
before
all those problems
they can be solved and they can be
solved by utilizing the laws of combat
leadership
and if a leader didn't step up and again
i don't care what leader i don't care if
it was an e5 i don't care if it was a
new guy if someone in the platoon didn't
step up and and start to
lead everyone would die
everyone would die
and
that was another interesting thing that
we could do sometimes is is pull take a
platoon guy and be like all right dude
you come walk with me on this run
and you can watch and you can see how
this unfolds and then you give them the
ability to detach or sometimes just
while some craziness is going on it walk
over like hey dude camera get off your
gun come over here
step back with me and look and see
what's going on do you see what's going
on yes do you know what decision to make
now
three seconds ago you had no idea what
to do because you were looking down a
corner pulling your trigger and nothing
was happening everything was stagnant i
pulled you off that corner someone
picked up for security for you now you
look around and it's really obvious what
you need to do isn't it yes it is so you
have to let people see
and feel like you were saying feeling
the the laws but feeling what it feels
like
to detach
and then they realize okay that needs to
be my protocol
that's what that's what i need to focus
on and the improvement and the learning
curve would be so fast once guys started
doing this like i said uh
by the end of the salk training by the
end of land warfare training the
platoons would be able to crush the
instructors most of the time
most of the time yeah occasionally
someone would have a failing troop and
they just couldn't get it together and
they would get recycled reloaded yeah
one of the things i wrote down when
you were first talking and then you said
it again is
just as a reminder when i when i was
acting as a role player
my
at the beginning of like them coming out
there for that training i would
literally just have on a pair of gator
sunglasses like not a mask nothing else
because i wasn't really worried about
being shot up too much like i just
i was really confident in my abilities
as an individual because when you're
moving as an individual if you're good
at what you do you actually have some
advantages
but as the training would progress along
the groups that were really starting to
get it i knew i was like oh this next
round's gonna be really bad for me it's
like i have a picture of me i'll try to
find it more one of the runs i didn't
have a i forgot to grab a ball of clava
or and i just had
my gator sunglasses and i got shot two
to three times in the face with
simunition and those plastic rounds were
like sticking out of my cheek and my
but
that's what would happen is when they
would use the laws of combat
we couldn't beat them even us use them
because
it's a full platoon yeah yeah and when
you're moving as a fire team i i can't
do anything unless i'm acting as a
sniper from a distance yeah i'm gonna
have that advantage but even then if
they're using the laws of combat and
they they understand the situation
then they're gonna they're gonna pin me
down they're gonna maneuver on me
they're gonna call in air support
they're
they are going to win
when they use the laws of combat
it's the same it's the same thing for
every aspect of your life i don't care
what your business is if you decide to
use a law as a combat you will win
personally and professionally and i just
remember like when guys would be
progressing and training i just knew i'm
going to get my ass kicked
and there was times that i got my ass
kicked as a role player and i
loved it because it meant that we were
doing our job 100 and it meant that
those guys were going overseas and what
they were going to do those enemy
fighters was going to be glorious
and they were all going to come home yep
and that was the purpose that's why that
was our mission yeah
yeah it was so rewarding to see them
start to step up and and see the leader
start to lead and see the e5 mafia start
to take control of stuff and
and then it would just be mayhem and
mayhem for the role players
you guys would be doing everything you
could cheat lie freaking sneak
bring yourselves back to life just do
everything you could and they would just
kick your ass because like you said
there's 40 of them
and there's maybe six seven role players
and you're just gonna get your ass
kicked oh well what if you come against
a force that's 40 you know why shouldn't
we train to fight against 40 people well
no we shouldn't because if we're not
gonna go fight a fair fight we're not
going to fight 40 against 40 enemy
fighters i'm gonna bring four thousand
yeah exactly um and we would put them in
scenarios like that as well where what
the right call would be to back off
leave
oh this building is so well defended
that you just kept throwing bodies at it
and throwing seals at it and they keep
getting killed keep getting killed keep
getting killed no just take a step back
get your jtac to drop a bomb on that
damn thing that's one of my favorite i
wouldn't i would say my top favorite
run that we do in the field training
exercise program is
it doesn't matter what they do if they
keep pushing forward
they're all going to die and it's not
until we get done and we in the scenario
and we end it right there
and we we do a debrief real time so they
can see it and feel it and they're like
[__] yep
and then it's like okay so you have a
business
you've invested in some
marketing campaign the return on
investment has been zero what should we
do go harder put more money into it okay
so we put more money into it what's the
return on investment now nothing
okay what should we do well it was my
plan i think it's a great marketing plan
let's put more money into it and we
continue to go down that path we don't
take a step back we let our ego drive
our decision-making process and we
realize that everyone dies we lose all
of our money all of our marketing money
for the year because we got committed to
a plan that didn't make sense
and so those the kinds of transfers of
knowledge that goes from this this thing
that you feel
during the ftx into a thing
that translates directly to how you're
running your business
we we call that scenario murder hole
[Laughter]
and it was really cool uh we we did that
with a group that we had going i mean
the amount of diversity of people that
come through our field training exercise
program is is incredible i mean we've
literally seen every walk of life come
through that training you have guys that
are super fired up i mean they've got
they got the jocko haircut they're
wearing the jocko t-shirt when they show
up they're wearing the origin boots
origin jeans i mean they are in origin
belt like head to toe origin jocko fuel
they're like jocko podcast stuff i mean
they're like ready to lead 100 yes
absolutely and then you have the
complete opposite spectrum
where it's an individual that you look
at them and you're like
okay they're not you know on on the path
when it comes to their health or
working out or you know just you could
tell that in some of them they don't
want to be there they're they're there
because their boss has made them come
because we do corporate and then
individual ones and i remember we were
doing it with this group and there
these people were they were too smart a
group of engineers
and we get done with that murder whole
scenario when we stop and we we
stop in real time to show them the train
and you know and this lady you know if
you were to judge a book by the cover
you're probably like hey she hates this
she doesn't want to be here like at the
beginning of the day that was just
probably her body language
we get down with this run and i'm just
talking through it and she goes can i
can i say something i'm like absolutely
she goes this represents and she goes
down this path of like something that
happened she goes
we were working on this coding problem
and it should have been like two weeks
she goes seven months later
and she goes this is that that's exact
this is what we do
all the time because of our egos we get
sucked into projects because of our egos
we need to actually detach and we need
to actually understand what our
priorities are she's going through every
all this i'm like
this is awesome that's it it was so cool
and she just has this big smile she goes
this is the best type of training i've
ever been to and then i was like all
right you guys ready for lunch and it
was like the run right before lunch we
go back and it was for me to sit back as
an instructor and and watch the guys run
the training and and have my points and
i have my points written down and then
for
the student going through the training
to literally
hit all my debrief points beautiful was
incredible because it shows that they're
actually taking on board what were
what we're telling to them but the
reason why is because the training is
humbling
like it's you're going to be humbled in
the training i don't
care who you are you you're going to be
humbled in that training
and that's what's awesome is because
that's when their learning really starts
to happen
yeah
the first time we tried it the first
time we tried an ftx with civilians
um you know leif and i were doing it
this is when the echelon front was
basically just life and me and yeah we
were we tried it and you know you don't
know what you don't know what the
reaction is going gonna be you don't
know if the people are gonna make those
connections those correlations between
leadership on the battlefield and
leadership and everything that they're
doing and it was so awesome i mean it
was you know a bunch of stories that
exact same type of story like oh this is
what we're this is you know ops never
supports sales this is the problem and
you're like oh you don't cover and move
for each other this is exactly right you
guys are never there for us and this way
so you get to see these things real time
and and as soon as we saw that
that
application and how well it correlated
that was when i was super stoked for you
to come over and with the long-term goal
of taking over that program running that
program
and and growing it so
talk me through talk talk us through
how what does that program look like
right now
not like the broad program but like
let's say i got a company
and i re i i hear about this thing and i
want to bring my team together
what am i doing what is my i got 20
people i got my leadership team my
executive leadership team what does the
program look like so it
we'll do a like a preliminary call with
the client to kind of figure out exactly
what they want to do and uh you know
jack daniel he's he's been doing all
those calls and then it's for an ftx he
then does another call with them and me
and jack's so awesome he's like bro
you're so busy i don't want to put and
i'm like hey if it's for an ftx
put on my calendar we're doing a call
and i just because i really want to
understand what their intent is what are
they looking to get out of it because
every ftx it's customizable
to your industry your problems what you
have going on now as you know the
principles are universal that's what's
beautiful about this and but but we can
make things to where they're different
than the others to drive home certain
points to to you and in your team so we
do that call
and then um you know now because of
covid the virtual world like we used to
have real quick examples yeah i'll have
a company and they're growing rapidly
and
the younger leaders aren't stepping up
and making things happen and on a call
they'll be like look we need to have
better decentralized command yeah and
then it's like hey jp
let's let's set up some runs to make
sure we really drive home the point of
how necessary it is for subordinate
leadership to step up and lead that's
the kind of adjustments
we're making so we can drive home
specific address specific issues that a
company has yep absolutely so we'll be
able to do that i put them in put in the
notes and then as we're building out the
scenarios
we'll be able to kind of change through
all the different scenarios
um but you know most of the time we do
a half day or a full day class ahead of
time to make sure everyone understands
the principles uh you know we talk about
the battle ramadi a lot of combat my
sister victory do some application
drills
if that's something they want if they
don't we just do a quick virtual to lead
them up to it because the ftx program
you're gonna learn the principles real
time so depending on the company's time
and or budget some companies they don't
have two full days where they can take
the full team out of the field that's
fine well we can send over a
pre-recorded video that everybody
watches or we can do a one-hour two-hour
three-hour virtual session ahead of time
to prepare them with the principles
and then we
we come to them or they come to us they
can come to different locations that we
have
the flexibility that we have with this
program is incredible and then the
actual ftx is it's all the hands-on
application so we'll show up in the
morning
we'll put them into their their squads
we'll sign the leadership positions
we'll give them an intel brief
and then they get a plan their first
mission and go out there and
i think did you skip
explain how you teach
you give um you know
mary
who's never handled the weapon before
yeah never been into uh never been never
handled a squirt gun before yep and now
all of a sudden you're gonna have her
clearing rooms and i know
when when we first started actually with
you i had to be like bro
you're not going to make these guys into
seals in
two hours
they need to have the basic fundamentals
of how to enter a room in a safe way in
a systematic way so they can clear well
that's that alone is a great example of
me
not asking enough questions from you and
life to get like your actual commander's
intent on the field training exercise
program because in my mind i'm like cool
i'm going to teach them tactics i'm
going to tie in leadership and it's
really important that they do all this
stuff and it's like
no actually i don't have to teach them
any of this because we're not here for
the tactics so yes
we start off we give them a hey here's
what to expect brief like it's in all of
our notebooks we we brief them on safety
we brief them on the fact that hey
you're going to impose more stress upon
yourself than is actually needed
everyone kind of chuckles i'm like just
you wait and see and then after first
couple runs everyone's like
man i am putting too much stress on
myself am man weird it's like we talked
about that and so we we run through all
this stuff to to set the stage so they
know what to expect
and then we
give them their gear and so we invested
into these high-speed laser tag systems
which by the way is what we used in lan
warfare we usually don't use those in
our urban training but in land warfare
in the seal teams we used a high-speed
laser tag system that this thing is the
civilian equivalent to yes it's freaking
legit it's and
that was a complete god thing because
when we were we ran a few ftx's it was
all it was airsoft and that's cool
because you're getting shot but there's
a there's a major safety concern with
airsoft and people are lifting up their
mass because they get fogged and like
having to stop training and it took away
the
from the purpose of the training which
was leadership and as we say all the
time communication is what ties
everything together and they couldn't
properly communicate doing airsoft or
paintball because the mask
so i reach out to a team guy buddy i'm
like hey i know you did like
some events for kids and you had laser
tags like can you give me that guy's
info so he sends it to me i look it up
i'm like oh these these aren't what you
would think for laser tags they're
pretty legit
it's not looking like a nerf laser no
it's not looking it's not like neon
green which by the way props to nerfs
i've i know you've heard me talk about
this those nerf guns the nerf lazy tag
guns that i raised my kids with are
freaking legit for teaching tactics by
the way just fyi yeah i mean
if you're teaching your kids that yes
um how it wasn't what we needed for the
ftx program and
we had a client
that was that told us hey we want to do
this but there we cannot do airsoft or
paint we cannot have any safety risks
i'm like
okay so i reach out team guy buddy gives
me the info i look up
35 minutes from my house from one where
you just moved there to texas and i'm
like okay thank you lord i go meet the
guy guy was a veteran expl i explained
to him what we're trying to do and he's
like well i'm actually changing these
systems to where they looked very
realistic and i was like okay this is
awesome so we invest into them
and so
we have the gear the sensors and so what
we do is we just
cody and the guys they give an awesome
class on hey here's how you use these
taggers these taggers
are tools just like you have tools that
work like you in order for you to get
the job done your tool has to be used
properly so we explain to them how to
use the taggers and so when we have
somebody that's super nervous i've had
people say
i'm not comfortable
with guns and i'm like that's good you
shouldn't be comfortable around guns
unless you have training that's a that's
a good feeling that you have
but once you understand the use of
weapons you shouldn't be scared if you
know how to use them properly
and i told this lady it's like it's the
same thing for these taggers one these
taggers can't hurt you that's why we
invested into them so even if you
accidentally pull the trigger and it's
pointed at you or somebody's face
you won't hurt them the lady's like okay
that's good i could she was super well
tight and rightfully so she had never
been around a weapon or a toy gun at all
and then um
which for me it was a realization of
like the things
i just take for granted of just my what
i've been around just it's not normal
for most people and so that was when we
really shifted over to
hey let's make them feel as comfortable
as possible like if they're not doing
something right make sure we're not
being like hey you know getting onto
them like we would team guys or marines
because
team guys and marines are very
good at going back to that default of
like hey you stupid like okay they've
never done this before so
we have all the guys there and they're
like helping them put on the sensors and
hey you want to plug in the sensor and
we go through a class and we say hey
these are your sops for how to use them
throughout the day before you you know
you you get your intel you plan the
mission you brief the mission you get
approval then you've got to go find the
key guy the key guy's going to turn on
your guns that key guy is a minimum wage
employee that's only job is to turn on
your guns
every single time we get that brief
every company is like oh we got one of
those guys
it's just a minimum wage person that
affects whether they can go do their job
the learning point there is
how do you treat that key guy
and we've had everything from
hey [__] you need to get our
guns on because we're running late and i
was like oh
i wonder how that works out for you yeah
excuse my language to all my church
friends that are listening i apologize
but that's like you were quoting someone
yeah but that's the extreme like we will
have that we're like
so we go we give the class and then we
let them have fun like all right hey
shoot the guns like shoot them as fast
as you can here's how you reload it we
teach them how to put like a basic
patrol and i always tell them like hey
guys these are not tactics these are the
basics these are tools single file dual
column here's how you get a head count
and so we give them enough
tools to where they can actually go be
successful in the first couple runs
based off of
the level of those first couple runs
when you talked about was interesting
just just to point out you were talking
about the amount of stress that gets
created and i just wanted to say that
a lot of times people think oh well you
know these are seals they must be
talking about all this physical stress
but it's actually
almost no physical stress
it's all it's all mental stress it's all
the confusion the chaos the mayhem and
because the physical this isn't a
physical evolution no this isn't a
physical evolution there's no in fact
you don't allow people to sprint or run
that's part of the inbrief no running
absolutely no running
for and for multiple reasons one safety
like hey if you run you roll your ankle
you hurt yourself
your trip fall you hit a tree you want
these buildings
now you're done and you've taken away
from the purpose of the training the
purpose of the training is
for us to work on our leadership skills
for you actually go through the runs
and i always tell the story of like when
you're running trade it when somebody
would do something they're not supposed
to
you would say hey stop doing the enemy's
job
you get arrested out in town you can't
deploy you get in a fight you break your
hand you can't deploy you can't run
training you can't do whatever you've
done the enemy's job so i always we tell
them that to make it real like hey
don't do the competition's job by taking
you out of this training you need to
finish this training people always say
is when you say don't do the
competitions job i love i love watching
people looks on people's faces body
posture change and
i mean we so to go back to that lady she
didn't even want to touch attacker and
i'm like cool just hey you know what
here let's get you a chair we brought
her a chair we had her sit down there
like hey just watch just watch the class
by the time we get done with the class
she comes up she's like hey
do you have an extra like set up for me
and i'm like callie will get you taken
care of and she goes over cali gets her
sized up runs through like hey real
quick let's make sure you're good with
it and that lady was a rock star yeah
well if you think about it from somebody
that's maybe not familiar at all with
the military not familiar at all with
weapons and they're just intimidated by
it and then they sit off to the side and
go oh wait a second this is legitimately
like they're playing tag yep but they
have teams this is a game that we're
about to play
and i i think i should play this game
and we're not going to get hurt so
that's another thing you know we'll work
with companies well you know we we got
people that aren't in the best physical
condition can they walk down a hallway
then then they can do this training and
what's interesting so we're saying all
this stuff look you can't run you can't
get hurt you can't shoot
or you're you're not going to shoot
somebody
um
no one's going to get injured you throw
all those things out it's like oh that
might be kind of lame right mm-hmm and
here's the thing i was just thinking
about like chief shy freaking police
chief oh yeah when the first time he
came through one of these things
totally blown away ft executives it's
the the leadership lessons that you
learn and we got we got all kinds of
vets going through going god i wish i
would have had this when i was in the
military so believe me even though it is
even though it is
like
it's it's contained and it's presented
in a way that is very
safe and very professional professional
and very um almost this is the word i
was looking for trying to find the word
benign it seems benign it's like oh wait
a second
we're like we can't even run and we're
just gonna be moving around and these
are just laser tag guns it seems super
benign you'd think oh this sounds like
it's not gonna be that big of a deal and
then you go to run number three where
people are like i need someone else over
here yeah we got another and we have
guys
total chaos yeah you're not supposed to
run and people are sprinting people are
going crazy people are losing their
minds people are giving orders that
don't make any sense all this stuff
happens from a benign
laser tag system
that's what happens that's what unfolds
it's crazy i mean
we've actually we we had a guy
that had um
multiple sclerosis
too he's like i mean he had like a cane
and so we were doing the classes he was
sitting in a chair my guys like took
care i remember watching how my guys
took care of them without me even having
to say anything and i
shocker got a little emotional watching
that because i was like my guys know it
they get it you know what i mean like
cody and coward were taking care of this
guy and he this guy had the biggest
smile on his face because he felt
because i know when he showed up i
remember he pulled me aside he was just
like hey i'm probably not gonna be able
to do anything and you could tell he was
upset because he wanted to be a part of
it and then when the guys were taking
care of him like for him saying like oh
this is cool it's on it's on to the
point where our guys were like cool all
right he can't keep up the group he's
not gonna be able to walk
we can drive him out to the play field
and so we would drive him out there the
role players would drive him off as a
sniper and he would be put in places and
it was awesome because i'm listening to
radio and i'm hearing the role players
go
dang it this guy keeps picking us us off
and he was
a huge part of the training um you know
this one lady came through she's like
hey i just got done with my chemo you
know i'm not going to be able to do too
much when we're like okay cool do what
you can we have positions for you you
can shadow me and act as the ground
force commander and relay information
and it was after two runs she was like
hey can i get in there and actually have
a position of leadership and i said
absolutely we changed up the reorg and
it was cool seeing people who showed up
with these self-imposed
limitations
they they came up with these excuses or
lack of better word for me i'm not i
mean this to them in a derogatory term
if they're listening but they had these
excuses as to why they wouldn't be able
to perform
and then when they realized
that that was all bs that that was
imposed upon by themselves nobody else
gave them those limitations they gave
them to themselves and they saw like oh
actually i can be a part of this oh i
can actually lead oh i can actually do
this i can learn
it's incredible i mean
just the transformation that you see
from we had a lady
who was like we
we gave out the leadership she comes up
she goes when you say gave out the
leadership what you mean by that is you
assign leadership for different
iterations yes okay
yes each run has a new set of leaders so
you like you're saying your company of
20 people everybody's going to go
through multiple positions of leadership
to where they feel all the different
like stresses oic officer in charge
assistant officer in charge squad
leaders fire team leaders or just the
shooter where you're just trying to
listen and do the work it's
it's incredible but the slaves you'll
learn something new in each one of those
levels and you'll see things differently
from each one of those levels and you'll
become a better leader by serving in
each one of those levels like denver
whitten from dagon construction came to
ftx001
and he was like super frustrated like
and he's a very motivated very smart
dude has a very successful construction
company out in the phoenix arizona area
and he came out to it and he was just
like
i remember i remember watching him and
listening to him the comments he would
say about the other guys and then he got
put in a position of leadership
and i think he said it to leif i'm
pretty positive he goes i now know what
my team feels
i now know what my team feels
and i've been doing all these things and
it was for him to have that aha moment
and then two weeks later he hit us up
and a week and a half later he goes hey
i need to run an ftx for
50 of my employees so we did two days of
ftx training with a half day classroom
on the back end of how do you implement
right strategically how do we implement
all these takeaways so you see all this
stuff happening
real time from all different walks of
life it's
it's ridiculous so i cut you off you're
talking about a female
yes so
thank you because i was like what where
did we go this one
um
so we give out the leadership
and she comes up and makes a comment and
goes well that's a mistake putting
females in charge
and i look at her and this is from a
company where
they have a culture where
if you say something offensive like
you're you get in a lot of trouble
and i looked at her i'm like if somebody
else said that to you would you find
that appropriate
and she just pauses
she goes well i'm just being real right
now i'm like well that's actually a lie
saying that just because a female is in
charge is going to go bad
i'm like that's a lot i was like i know
a lot of badass females that run
companies that are kicking ass i know a
lot of badass female leaders in the
military that did some phenomenal things
i'm like
don't
oh so she was like serious when she said
oh she was dead serious she wasn't she
was dead serious like okay just like
this is gonna be horrible like body
posture like like gun down to the side
like
and i was like okay so immediately i'm
like there's something there like
there's something deeper there obviously
for her to be like she was not thrilled
and just thought i was gonna be bad
so i talked with carlos and cody like we
give the intel
pull them aside i'm like okay we just
keep an eye on her we need to
like pour into her because she thinks
it's going to be horrible like we need
to make sure she gets the burp and lows
and cody like yep got it
cool
we go do the run obviously we put a
bunch of stress on her so we wanted her
to feel it like we do everybody it
wasn't any different but we were just
very mindful of making sure we were
watching and i s you know
because we've had some people come to
the training where they just stop
they're like hey i can't do this is too
much i'm like
yes you can like
come come over here real quick let's
talk through it and they're like
okay and this one guy was like
that was all me i put too much stress
sorry i won't let that happen again
self-imposed stress it was to the point
where the guy wanted to stop training
he tried to physically stop the training
so i want to make sure this didn't
happen to this lady just fyi if you feel
like you are too stressed this is a
massive red flag that's telling you to
detach take a step back take a breath
which is as soon as you you said that
guy okay step back take a breath he's
like oh okay i can see what's going on
all right i'm ready to rock and roll
yeah
and
and so i really felt
like i just
i knew there was something else with
with this lady so we get back from the
run it it was hard but guess what they
accomplished what they're supposed to
accomplish we get done with the run
we're doing the debrief
and it's in one of my notebooks i
remember wrote down what she said um but
the greater point was just
the limitations she had and i asked her
because she said something or her
takeaway was
uh don't limit what you're capable of
and that was like awesome and i said
expand upon that a little bit
and she goes well i just i didn't think
i'd be capable of this position
and i said why she goes well it's it's a
little bit deeper i'm like
what do you got like this is like this
is the time for let's talk through it i
said if you're comfortable if you're
comfortable with it she goes well
for my past
i said okay like
and i know i'm like
riding a line that this could go really
close
but i also knew as an opportunity that
if we could talk through something that
she never has to go through again or
just is able to let go of something then
our day has been worth it like you know
that's what we're here for is stuff like
this
because that's going to make her a
better leader if she can let go of these
you know limitations that she's put on
herself she goes well when you come
from another career where your life was
threatened
and you know you you know your life was
actually threatened
she goes because
you weren't doing what you should have
done she was like i
i carry that
what was her old job
we didn't ask
i just didn't feel like it was a time um
i should have afterwards just to get a
little more like
i guess information or situational
awareness
but you know and we talked through it
and i said well hey i'm glad that you
came to that realization like these are
one that's the purpose of the training
is for us to fill these things and
realize like hey
these tools work when we use them and
all the other stuff that we have in our
mind it a lot of it's all bs because
it's that's not the reality
and then we did our end of the day
debris like our key takeaway so we do
all the runs we rotate through different
positions
and then at the very end it's like hey
what was
what was your biggest takeaway that
you're gonna
leave this training with to implement
back home and hers was you know same
thing like i'm not gonna let my past
define me she goes today is a fresh
start
and
i i always try to
explain that when i'm talking with
clients is like that's what you did when
you came in and tasked in a bruiser hey
we're not attaching a bravo we're
tasking a bruiser all the other stuff
doesn't matter
like this is who we are and this is what
we're going to do
and i like to also tie that in
when i'm talking about ramadi you know
when we talk about like hey will you
come back from the point when we talk
about the cost and the burden and all
that stuff
i try to make it very clear when i'm
talking with individuals or large groups
like
we're all going to have those dark times
we're all going to have those things
from our past that
could hold us back if we allow them to
but if that's all we focus on like anger
frustration darkness guilt doubt all
that it gets us nowhere and i know we've
talked about this multiple times but we
have to focus is the lessons that you've
learned
and more importantly what are you going
to do going forward and that's the big
thing that we talk about in the field
training exercises like yes
hey you guys made mistakes but what are
we going to do going forward as a group
if we're not sitting and debriefing and
coming up with new standard operating
procedures we're wasting our time
if we were just to reorganize all right
hey new leadership go new leadership go
new leadership go
there wouldn't there would not be that
progression that we get if it wasn't for
the debriefs and
the debriefs are an awesome opportunity
for you to do some self-reflection
and that's what's powerful is that
self-reflection
yeah well what's interesting about that
is
this this
training program
in situations like this which
i've seen and you've seen
when it goes
beyond
business application beyond the combat
application obviously beyond the
business application and it starts to
get into people's souls
and
sitting there listening to people
debrief
seeing
grown men
weeping because they realize that
they've made mistakes in their lives
seeing you know women apologizing for
behavior that they know they they
shouldn't have done and it was
negatively impactful to their family
like seeing those
deeper
those deeper changes
that's always uh it's always amazing to
see
that this stuff applies and gets through
yeah
gets through to people's souls
it does
i mean
one of our larger field training
exercise clients one of their upper
executives
you know the company i'm talking about
everyone that we've been interacting
with since 2018 running these ftx's all
of those key leaders
they they don't just know the principles
they actually live their principles they
apply them they believe in them
and guess what
every single one of those individuals
has grown within the ranks like multiple
tiers of now high level executive
leadership positions and the individual
i'm talking about he's just been in the
game since day one with us helped us
bring the program to them
he sent me a text and i always forward
them to you and leif and and jamie and
dave just so we're all aware of like the
impact that we're truly delivering i
know we know it and i always give it to
my team and i i like to if i'm in person
with the guys be like hey
just so you guys know this is what
you're a part of
and as we grow this you're gonna have
more and more and more of this because
if we do what we teach
and we do it the right way which we are
you all are going to have teams
eventually running this training and
this is what you need to focus on is the
impact that we deliver everything else
it's important but it's the impact that
we deliver that's what you have to like
strategically that's what i want you
guys thinking about and he sent this
text where one of his
his executives that
works directly his his direct report
said
that training fed my soul thank you
i didn't realize it's what i needed
holy crap
it's just
it's incredible to see that impact and
i wrote this down it's one of the things
you're talking about is when you were
running training
you said
literally we could almost do whatever we
wanted
so i wrote down wide boundaries
leadership capital withdrawal return on
investment
so
it reminded me
of when we went back and you were
running training and we literally could
do whatever we wanted
and the reason why is because the
training we produced delivered results
it we had guys come back from deployment
saying
the hard training you guys put us
through
kept us alive
it kept us alive and i remember when i
was being an absolute jackass at
training
i won't be very clear i i've said this
multiple times i always want
i know i'm in a unique position working
at echelon front
i wasn't this phenomenal leader in the
seal teams i wasn't like seth
or leif or you or dave i was in some
unique positions and there was times
where i was a good leader but i also
know that i was a jackass and that i was
you know that i was that that guy that
my leadership had to deal with so
there's no there's no one on the t
there's no one at the echelon front team
that doesn't have that caveat bro no one
just fyi yeah but i might i mean we want
to start pulling apart you know yeah
yeah go deep how deep you wanna go i
know but
there's no one that's why we're here yes
and i know but i also know
that because i have that background
perspective i do at times appeal to a
larger base
than some of the other instructors
because
i can relate to all the different levels
and and i get that so i want to be when
i'm like talking through this stuff i
want to be like i don't think i was this
phenomenal like perfect leader in the
military i was
a good team guy i think i think i was a
good team guy i believed in the mission
and i remember when you pulled me aside
because i was struggling with some
personal stuff that was starting to
affect me professionally
that's when you told me like hey
your job
is to be the best damn instructor that
you can be so that we don't have to put
our uniform on to go to another funeral
and i know i've shared that story before
multiple times
is when i realized that
it just changed my
perspective
and when we started delivering that
impact
that's why we were able to do whatever
with with training
and
because the amount of leadership capital
that you built within our community by
delivering the absolute best training
it allows us to make large withdrawals
but if you make a large withdrawal that
has a high return
you're actually at a higher level when
you come back it's like basic investing
i'm gonna pull a hundred dollars out but
it's gonna make me 150
cool keep doing that
every time you've ever made a withdrawal
in your
career especially in tasking a bruiser
and i trade it
the return on that investment was
ridiculous
and that's what we try to tell companies
like hey
if you're gonna make a withdrawal
there better be a large investment
there better be a large investment and
the more
relationships you have within your team
the more trust the more trust you have
the more influence and you can actually
go out and do those things and that's
what people see real time
in the training yeah i remember you had
a situation there was a safety incident
took place and the report came back
[Music]
if we hadn't just gone through this
training this would have been a complete
disaster if we hadn't just gone through
this ftx training this is a um let's say
a
a oh yeah a company that does dangerous
work you know dangerous construction
type work they had a safety incident
take place and they reported
if we hadn't
been through this training whatever it
was two weeks ago this would have been
an unmitigated disaster we were able to
get control of it prioritize and execute
and decentralize command we made things
happen and got the problem solved much
quicker than we would have had we not
been through this year so i've talked
with the leadership about that and i
asked like hey how can i share this what
can i share because i know some of it's
sensitive
so i'll share what i know we can share
there is actually a death on a job site
and
it was we had been running a week of ftx
training
and it was on a friday it was a
beautiful day and i remember we came
back from one of our runs and i was
looking around and i could see people's
posture changing as they were looking at
their phones
and one of the guys comes up to me and
he has tears in his eyes and he said hey
one of our guys just got killed on a job
site and it brought me back to when when
seth was like hey
mark just got killed it it brought me
right back to them
and i remember sitting wow
that's all i could think about is just
like
i i didn't think i was dealing with this
stuff anymore
and so
i said all right you know you guys kind
of let me know i'll give you guys some
time to kind of think about it and
everyone's kind of like checking they're
talking and there's a few people crying
and they're upset
and
so i make an announcement to the ftx
team and and to the client you know and
i just shared with them i said you know
hey
i told you you guys deal with human life
just like we did in the seal teams and
you guys have a very dangerous job
but it's a very critical job as well if
you guys don't do what you do people can
suffer
like people's lives and businesses can
suffer bad
so it's necessary that you guys do your
job but it's very dangerous so we go
through this whole talk and i you know i
said hey i know one of you guys have to
leave because it's actually your your
teammate
i said you guys have hit all the
training objectives
and so we can be done
and this would be a good day of training
or we can do one more run
and we can do it to honor this gentleman
that just got killed
because i'm telling you right now
leadership is what's going to solve
every problem within this organization
if we pulled the thread
there was a leadership failure somewhere
that allowed this complacency to creep
in and this individual just got killed
because what this guy was doing he had
done thousands of times over his career
it was literally thousands of times
and so we finished the run we finished
the day strong that was a friday
we had another week with them that we
were supposed to do at the end of that
month
two days later we get an email from the
leadership saying hey we'd like to talk
to you guys about you know some stuff so
we we get on a phone call with them and
they're like hey can we do another two
to three weeks worth of training before
the end of the year
we're like i don't know if we can we
might i think we might have a two-week
block open in december but
december in your region is miserable and
they're like
here's the deal so they took the reason
why
is because when the executives
showed up
on this location where this individual
had been killed
it was a situation they'd never seen
before
because there was no pointing of fingers
there's nobody blaming it wasn't the
union blaming corporate corporate
blaming you there is none of that when
they showed up everything would have
been taken care of the executive
leadership was being told what they
needed to go do hey we're already doing
this you guys need to go do this boom
boom boom
everything had been taken care of and
there was no blame there was no arguing
none of that
and then the ceo
and some of the other leaders sat down
with the union president and some other
leaders i was like hey
how do we make it toward this never
happens again
and a union president said we go all in
with the echelon front leadership
training that's the only thing that's
going to keep this from happening again
and the ceo goes okay and the executives
are right all right we'll see what we
can do
and that's when they came back to us and
said hey we want another two to three
hundred leaders put through this
training
and so we put 400 liters for that
in 2018 2019 we're supposed to do a
bunch more
and we have continued to have a great
working relationship with this with this
client but
it was a union president
that was telling the executives
we need to go all in with this training
because he saw firsthand
well the reason why everything was
running so smooth
at that fatality
was
the leaders
had gone through our training earlier
that week
that's that same week
and you know it was you know i've had a
few members from that company go
it was a complete godsend that we had
your guys's training that week because
it was a real it was a real hard thing
for them to handle
and
i mean
they've also explained to us like how
their culture has changed
i mean it's been a drastic
and you know you know some of the
details it's awesome
of just change and it's just
you know when when we talk about
complacency and leadership solving
people's problems
and we kind of get personal
and we explained to them like hey
that problem is a leadership problem
that is a leadership problem and you
allow complacency to creep in
people get offended at first
they they get offended but then we kind
of change the tone like let's pull the
thread
if we pull the thread enough it goes
back to a leadership problem that
allowed the complacency to creep in
because if we go to war with that
complacency and we combat it and we do
what we're supposed to do we mitigate
all those things that's what we talk
about being default aggressive that's
what we tell people hey default
aggressive isn't
a mindset for victory against another
human being
now in combat yes but we're not talking
about that
we're talking about being default
aggressive to
improve a relationship
work on your communication being default
aggressive to mitigate safety risks
and if you're
not allowing that complacency to creep
in because
of the leadership that you have
because the culture culture is the
ultimate form of decentralized command
and so if your team knows what they're
supposed to be doing they don't cut the
corners therefore we keep our people
safe and it enables like you're talking
about in that scenario like hey i'm not
having junior leaders step up
they see enough in in the scenarios that
we run
there's a void of leadership guess what
we should do
oh johnny step up i don't have an
armband i'm not a leader
and i just look and i tilt my head and
they're like roger that you know
and it's just it's amazing yeah it's it
is you know all problems are leadership
problems and what does that mean the
beautiful thing about that is that means
leadership is the solution and that
means that we can solve the problem we
can solve these problems it's liberating
and that is a a powerful powerful thing
um
hey man
i mean we work with so many different
companies i was gonna i was about to i
was about to close it but it's like hey
that's one company and we work with all
these different companies i know tech
companies financial companies uh
manufacturing companies construction
companies energy companies and just
every different facet and every
different type of group you know from
the tech world to the financial world
and the lessons are learned and the the
culture is changed and leadership
rises to the surface to be the solutions
the problems that these companies have
yeah i have to show i have to show love
for groundworks because you talk about a
client that's in the game for sure i
mean
matt malone i call him mr malone he
always gets pissed off at me he's like
it's matt and i'm like
okay i have a real i can't just do that
i have a hard time i can't you know ever
since i was a kid that's the way i was
raised but
matt at groundworks i mean he saw the
power of extreme ownership he read the
book and was like hey this is this is
what i've been looking for came to a
muster pay for some guys to go the
muscle with them came back was like hey
we want to engage with you guys we did a
we did a
little trial ftx with with a bunch of
their leaders and when they saw that ftx
they're like
okay we need this
i won't get into all the details of how
they run their business and what they're
doing but i can tell you they are
extremely
successful growing expanding dominating
the marketplace like dominating
and one of the cool things that they do
is every small every company they
acquire their their goal is they're
acquiring small to medium companies in
their industry
within 90 days
they run an ftx it's legit and the
reason why they do that is to show this
new company that they acquired their
commitment to them to develop them as
leaders to give them hope to give them
like the tools to lead and be successful
and
he says there's no better program out
there to implement the lessons and the
principles that we need but also
to tie in the culture yeah because it's
like hey this is how we do things at
groundworks you're now part of our tribe
yes you're still this company right
you're whatever that company is you're
still them
but you're also a part of our tribe
and it's
i mean just to see like i get the
goosebumps like
to see companies that are that committed
to see an individual like matt that
that's com that is that committed to
their company's growth
and development it's impressive i just
shared with you
one of the personal examples of that guy
that pulled me aside recently was
yeah i mean just it's incredible yeah
it's a it's a huge impact and that's a
great example like you said of the
of a company that is just taking these
taking these leadership principles i've
been applying them continuing to
applying them applying them at scale yes
which is awesome and continuing to see
success after success after success
that's
[Music]
that's another great example of the many
companies that we work with that go out
there
take these principles implement them and
dominate
yeah and it shows them one thing that
i've written down i wanted to hit is
the importance of like
like the diversity of people's like
different people's ideas and backgrounds
um that's one thing i was talking with
the company i'm like
the reason i feel one of the reasons why
the seal teams were so successful
is because we have like true diversity
of skill sets and thoughts in in how we
conduct business hey i can have a a
platoon full of 18 jockos and that's
going to be an awesome platoon
but
he doesn't have all the things that i
need not as good as a platoon full of 18
different people yes
not even close yes and i only see what
things one way my perspective and that's
not what we want i want to have 18
different perspectives yes and that's
what people see real time in the ftx
program is as everyone's rotating
through different position positions of
leadership
we actually we develop this workbook for
them so that afterwards they can capture
their their takeaways
and you see the the takeaways evolving
as the day goes on because there's all
these different ideas and thoughts and
the diversity of a company that now they
say like oh
so and so
like her ideas are awesome his ideas are
awesome let's get them to work together
and at the end of the day when they
start working together when they start
applying the principles
it sucks for my role players yep well
that's that's what i was talking earlier
when we kicked this thing off i was
talking about a seal platoon
and i was like oh you got all these
different types of people in the seal
platoon
and you got some smart guys you got some
educated guys you got some uneducated
guys you got some short guys some tall
guys some slow guys some fast guys you
got somebody that was born with a silver
spoon in their mouth you got someone
that was raised in the ghetto you've got
all these different people with all
these different perspectives and
that makes that platoon strong that's
what it is it's not like you said 18
jocko's cool that's great but that's not
as powerful as 18 individuals that all
bring a different perspective a
different mindset a different viewpoint
and that's what makes a platoon strong
is all the differences that people have
they they you get to see more you get to
see the problem you get to see a problem
from multiple different angles
you know when we
when we go out in the field and do a
reconnaissance of a target
we don't just look at the target from
one side
we do a cloverleaf around the target we
we back out we go in from another angle
we go all the way around so we can see
as many different angles of the problem
so that we can figure out how to solve
it so
if you have 18 jockos that's one
viewpoint if you have 18 individuals you
got that clover leaf you get to see as
much of that target as you can possibly
see and that's how you're going to solve
the problems
i'm smiling because you're saying the
cloverleaf i just i watched cody
do this with a group
the other week they're briefing their
plan
and they're just kind of sitting there
listening and you could tell like it
wasn't the right plan
and so what him and carlos do instead of
saying hey you should do this they just
ask questions yeah hey
what if like so i see you have your guys
right here and you have your guys right
here
and so they're split so that would be
split forces right so we want to make
sure they know what we're talking about
and then carlos just goes if somebody
pops up in the middle you have to shoot
like
would you be able to shoot them
and it's
every single time like the client
who has zero tactical yeah training goes
oh that's yeah we shouldn't do that we
shouldn't split forces right yeah that's
a good idea and cody built this train
map for the large client that we have
that we have all the work with he built
a actual 3d terrain map of the play
fields that we use
and they were going through some stuff
and cody just grabbed the oic who was on
one side of the table looking at it and
brings them around to the other side i
was like hey what do you see
and you're this is nothing major but
just the changing of that guy's
perception from over here he saw it in a
different way he goes
yeah we shouldn't probably go up that
way and cody's like i like your plan
check hey you've been talking about a
bunch of our corporate clients but also
yep what was it last year was that last
year we started the first ftx individual
ltx well this year march
okay so if somebody wants to like let's
say i'm just fred and i this sounds
awesome and i got i got a small company
i can't i can't bring an echelon front
to teach my company because i only got
22 employees but i got three people my
main you know subordinate my two team
leaders i want to bring them so we have
a program for that too and how's that
work yeah so we have the individual
program the individual ftx program to
where an individual like you just said
can sign up and come to the training or
a guy like denver wetton who's like i
think i want this
but i'm not sure like let me go test it
out he came to the training tested it
out and me it was like i need two days
worth of this training um and so we went
to the next one the next one is in april
um
i want to say april so it's not the
dates aren't locked down yet no
i'd have to put my camera okay but
we'll go to echelonfront.com go to go to
um
events muster individual one so
ftx004 it's gonna be in dallas fort
worth so we're gonna be back in dallas
again in april in april so it's kind of
cool yes the weather's gonna be perfect
yes and it's so it's the last week in
april whatever that monday tuesday is i
wanna say like 23rd 24th something like
that
um that we'll be having that one in
april and then we're looking depending
on how that one sells out we have some
we already have corporate clients that
are like putting locks in our calendar
on 2022 for ftx's i know so ftx 005 and
006 we're not sure those dates and
locations yet but
right now and it's gonna sell every the
first three sold out uh it's gonna be in
april so an individual can sign up for
it
it's two full days of training so you're
getting two full days of those field
training exercises
well we'll do the check in meet and
greet on sunday give out the
pre-mission bags with all their gear
and then on monday we start the class we
do overview
we give the classes and then the run
admissions all day we have a team dinner
and then like kind of open q a with you
leif myself
and then on tuesday full day run of
missions and then we'll do jiu jitsu
afterwards as well yeah and um awesome
debrief at the end to kind of capture
and make sure everyone gets it
well freaking right on um
awesome i'm so glad you came to ashland
front
and you're taking this thing and running
with it it's just it's amazing to see
the impact uh on individuals on
companies on businesses on teams it's
just how freaking awesome and that we're
able to take these lessons and and pass
them on and people can put them to use
to go out there and just and just do
what they're supposed to do in the world
yeah it's awesome yeah
well thank you for the opportunity once
again
yeah uh echo charles yes sir
we're over here you know we're running
ftx's and we're uh we're doing jiu jitsu
we're lifting sure you know
yes learning leading right seems like we
might
want to get all the help we could get in
some of these departments what you know
it's true what do we got for support
recommendations
uh well well we can talk about a lot of
stuff but you know in the physical
capability realm okay yeah we do uh
appreciate the support when we can get
it
wait jp's here why don't we just talk
about sour apple sniper all day
you know we could we could jp
okay let's rewind you're at trade with
me
how many energy drinks are you drinking
a day
what do you think you're what do you
think your worst like your max energy
drinks a day
was
and we're talking like the big ones that
had 300
oh that was six to seven eight
oh i know it's not good
yeah that's bad that's bad no it's real
bad yes sir it's a freaking disaster it
was absolutely
yeah
god all right so what are those means
where people are like this is my body
like with all the check lights like oh
yeah i can check out lights all over the
place
that was that was you me i traded
me on the outside doing sales as a
financial company
it's been me for a long time but not
anymore that yeah like
i don't know we're talking about that
and you know like
whatever say whatever you want about me
i
don't have i could not make something
like that and sell it to people i
couldn't yeah as far as i'm concerned i
might as well be a drug dealer that that
that is a drug dealer that is a that is
a person that has
given
freaking crystal methamphetamine to
people and
and knowing that they're going to get
addicted to it knowing that you're
hurting their health probably going to
kill them and you don't care because i'm
making money i could not do that from a
moral standpoint as a human couldn't do
it
zero chance
and yet
i kind of felt like i got to do
something because otherwise people are
out there
they're visiting the meth dealers
right going to 7-eleven there's a meth
dealer in there yeah in a in a freaking
uh uh icebox
and
there's a short-term benefit
that you need that i need sometimes that
echo charles needs sometimes hey you
need hey look it's a long day whatever
it's
last night i got
i don't know i guess i got like three
and a half hours of sleep i actually
woke up at 4 30 i was like okay if i'm
not feeling it i'm gonna go back to bed
i was like i need more sleep i tried to
go back to bed i couldn't go back to bed
i couldn't go back to sleep so i just
got up worked out and
but then i then then we're in here
i'm tired
or i was tired when i showed up then i
so what do i need
i need something to help get over that
fatigue
what do i need oh i'm going to have one
of these things do i want to go down to
do the crack house and buy some rocks
because that's going to hype me up too
right
it's going to hype me up
right that's a terrifying thought
yeah it's going to hype me up but guess
what it's going to kill me yes so we're
not doing that no so we made something
that you can drink that's
literally good for you literally no
downside
makes you feel
hype hype is that a good word well
approved disapproved is not you know
you're shaking your head i sense it i'm
not there yet we'll say that what would
be a better word
i was digging deep through the old vocab
i like i like fired up that's the
traditional i don't like though uh i
don't know
i think i'd prefer hype over fired up
hype it is then i'm mad
jp anything better than that
i mean not everyone's gonna fully get
this but there's a few times i've
cracked these open i just tell myself
activate yeah that's true yeah you want
to get out there that brings me back to
like jacques jp activate on the radio
there you go
yeah if you follow me on instagram if
you ever see you
on a post and if i have a hashtag
activate it's for that it's just hey
just
yeah so when jp
jp would be the bad guy one of the bad
guys and the platoons would be like
trying to work through a problem or
whatever and they'd just be screwing
something up screwing something up
screwing something up and they needed to
pay the man
i just come up on the radio like
jp
activate
and he would come out of a spider hole
or a false wall with a with a mark 46 a
freaking simulation and just lay waste i
remember one of the times i was like
waiting for it i'm not gonna say his
name because he's still in but his
nickname man bear pig
so
which was very fitting for this
human being yeah it was terrifying
and he was like now the new lpo and his
towards my end as i was getting out and
i was just like waiting i was like he
could tell he's like hey
he's like wait wait until jocko gives a
call and i'm just like freaking out like
just like waiting because i was so hyped
up
i mean i i loved what i did i loved
every single day of being in the sealed
teams and it's the same thing now at
echelon front running these field
training i mean people were like man i
don't like you i don't get it like how
do you keep on like because i love i
literally love what i'm doing
and it was like the same thing he's like
wait just wait hold like hold like hold
and all of a sudden you're like jp
activate he's like go
so if you need to activate activate i
like it boom
if you need to activate freaking crack
open one of these and you'll get
freaking activated kick out that door
start laying the waste with a mark 46.
yes the right way
yes nope no price you don't pay no price
later no no you just go we're not doing
the freaking nazi thing putting our guys
on uh on meth yeah yeah they deal with
the devil you know yeah it's like oh
what do you need oh you need that oh
yeah okay and then they collect that
check afterwards right you're in big
trouble sometimes big trouble that
withdrawal jp was talking about that
withdrawal not what we're looking for no
no no all good so yes jaco discipline go
or are we going with jocko go because
it's kind of interchangeable kind of
interchangeable yeah that's the energy
drink that's the one that we want this
one we want to stick with sour wrappers
sour apple sniper it's a good flavor
dude they're all good flavors they're
they're all good flavors and i can tell
you personally
the ftx program is run and fueled by the
discipline goes because we get them sent
to every location ahead of time
jack daniels just he's in the game he
takes care of that i used to do it he's
like i got it i'm like oh he's like jp i
got
we have them at every ftx for our team
for all the prep ahead of days ahead of
time all the stuff they're doing
um and then also for the client as well
and we have to put it out like hey
you these are healthy but you don't need
to drink one after every single run
because they taste so good we had one
guy i was like watching and i was like
hey he's like what's up i'm like come
here real quick he's twitching well no
because you literally could drink six of
these and be equal to two of those
larger drinks from the devil
and and so
i pull them aside i'm like hey how many
he's like i've had one after every run
i'm like
you're drinking water for the rest of
the day i'm like you're good
it's still like not an unhealthy level i
said but man like you're just you don't
need to be doing that he's like they
just taste so good i'm like no i want
that i was like i'll let you in on a
little secret i know that in the future
they're talking
about hopefully having
caffeine-free versions he's like okay
dude he was so excited this guy was in
the game
we'll get there oh yeah and
it makes sense good because the you know
how when you drink a different drink or
whatever you drink one you're like cool
you drink two and you're like okay two's
kind of good whether it be the flavor
the heaviness of it or whatever doesn't
have that and has electrolytes too so i
can dig it he's drinking one after every
run yeah
i suggest mango
that's my suggestion i was talking to a
gentleman
i'm not a little bit a little bit biased
but hey maybe it's the you're biased too
jp you said i said they're all good they
are you gotta throw out the bias okay so
one guy he was talking to me he was like
hey i'm gonna um
i'm gonna try either the orange or the
mango
yeah carrot was with me he witnessed
this whole thing okay and i said okay
you're asking me this okay all right i
said i think if you want to go a little
bit more exotic a little bit more risk
try mango yeah if you want to go to the
the the fried and true
you go orange yeah i think uh sour apple
sniper is kind of like on on the same
level as mango as far as that goes i
think no i don't think so you think it's
more tried and true no i think it's
tried and true
the the thing with the sour apple
is it's the sours
it's a lot more it's a lot more sweet
than sour i mean it freaking tastes good
good it's sweet it's freaking sweet so
orange is sweet
sour apples definitely sweet mango
has some exotic
to it
it's still sweet yeah it's sweet
um yeah so a lot of people they like
they love they love loving they think
it's like way better but then some
people are just straight up not down
actually one person
for the mango yeah you mean me yes
you're right i don't like mango that
that savage will throw you off because
you don't know and then you taste you're
like oh yeah like
why is this so good like you're trying
to figure it out and people that loved
you know dakota meyer starting a
distribution company
yeah as he should yeah he just decided
he's just gonna become a distributor of
the drinks yeah so he started just
rolling into places and now
he's just going on the war path so i've
like not at that level i think so he he
was talking to amanda about it at the
vegas muster
and she's like that's that's amazing um
you know that's how i got introduced to
the new jiu jitsu gym i'm at is through
dodeco it's for mega right and at his
gym double five and it was setting him
up so i have
i don't even know how many gyms i have
under me as like wholesalers because i
can set up them at the same thing yeah
and then i found out uh
um the dakota was doing that as well
yeah he's doing that like freaking he's
got grocery stores and stuff yeah dude
he's so awesome
so yes
stay in the game
over here oh good of course very
exciting stuff but yes stay in the game
with all this stuff helpful i've had
today by the way i didn't eat breakfast
or lunch and
i had one of these at the house same
here yeah it's good two of the pills
with it just you know got to make sure
you're
floating in your bottle for the flight
um also don't forget about your joints
don't forget you know you talk about
complacency creeping in
like not
but yeah but sometimes that that'll come
on slowly where you don't notice then
one day you're looking at you're like
man am i gonna feel like i gotta warm up
just to live my normal life right you
don't want that no so you take the joint
warfare the super krill oil just keep
keep everything in line man it's good
you'd be happy you did also vitamin d3
and cold water this is for you immune
immunity yeah
greens by the way just have the green
freaking you're saying some good stuff
about the greens
they're really good yeah but you used a
particular case
you did
i thought you were going to go into it
i thought that was like pre-podcast talk
but i guess no no no no no
let's say you have uh some cocktails or
some wine with your significant other
sure
so amanda and i were having some have
some drinks
and uh you know the next day i'm like
this is exactly why i don't drink i
don't drink i don't drink for this
reason
went and grabbed two scoops of the
greens
half water half apple juice
tasted phenomenal
it felt amazing afterwards
greens greens greens is kind of amazing
it's kind of a miracle you can also do
it right before bed like so if you have
some drinks
you know maybe you shouldn't be drinking
and but you do and
one or two scoops of the drink of the
greens water right before bed so we got
hangover prevention
we didn't even know it official we
didn't even know it but we have it if
we're talking about the um you know how
you feel things real time like when i
have
the greens
i feel really good
really good
study sample size of one you know that's
where it starts 100 percent for the
factual it's true factually also milk
don't forget about milk you want some
additional protein
yeah
it's hard it's hard to forget about
moisture right right
but yes that's a that's a dessert
there's nothing there's nothing there's
nothing that you just sit there like
you'll be into some a random spot
and just think man i really want to bowl
right now
that's the thing
there's no other even steak even steak i
won't have a i won't have a a craving
for a steak as much as i will have a
random yes i really want a mulk right
now yeah yeah that's how tasty have you
have you mixed soothing have you mixed
the greens with the milk no i have not
done that that's bold it's bold think
about this vanilla gorilla with the
greens
getting crazy over here it's really
exciting
yeah because if you know vanilla protein
powder with fruit right if you're if you
want to make a smoothie you're gonna put
some frozen fruit in there right well
the greens have that fruit flavor the
pineapple and the coconut so it's it's
really good interesting because yeah
that's kind of how mo the nature of milk
can be is you mix some other stuff in
there a lot of hey look i stick with the
chocolate so if i put anything in the
chocolate put a little bit of a frozen
banana and that's sort of ripe
oh yeah that's the one right there but
yeah especially with the vanilla you can
mix all kinds of stuff in there yeah
just enhance it it's good you know
tulsi's done a lot of amazing things in
her life yes sir and the only thing that
you seem to care about is that she told
you to put half right bananas in your
freaking monk bro that girl's a damn
veteran
she's a congresswoman she's a surfer
she's a fighter and you're over here
talking about rotten bananas going into
mulk and that's like the deal well let's
face it uh tulsi's surfing abilities and
you know her service and stuff play less
of a role in my day-to-day life check
okay
but i'm just saying that frozen banana
uh mulk let's face it it's facing kind
of a game changer yeah
daily she didn't do much for you as a as
a representative of of hawaii she didn't
do much of you as a combat vet going
overseas that didn't help you out but
day to day
she's all up in that mulch
the mulk train she gives good advice hey
you get the drinks you get the drinks at
wawa on the east coast we're going into
a bunch of other stores right now i'll
keep you posted on all of that uh you
can get the you can get everything at
vitamin shop
go hook up the vitamin shop and look you
can get all of it at jockofield.com and
if you subscribe there's no
shipping payment which is a big deal
because look let's face it there's other
companies out there you might have heard
of some of these companies and they're
get you on this little
thing where you're getting stuff shipped
to your house for free and that can be
hard to compete with
how do you compete with it just do a
little subscription activity help us put
down the big boys but if there is an
issue with your order that if you
ordered from jockofield.com or
germaine.com
then you reach back out to origin and
jockofield and they fix it
the the other ways that you can get it
like if there's an issue with your order
there's an issue with your order that's
it just play jocko feel and origin
they're going to resolve that problem
they're going to take care of it and
they're going to make it right
yeah that's true also you may mention
origin origin usa.com it is the origin
main too right it is all the same gig
this is american-made stuff denim boots
belts wallets whatever else pete thinks
up there's a heavy hoodie and they're a
great thing i don't have one but you
know
that's got to be
i i understand you're over there with
rotten
rotten bananas we got heavy hoodies i
just want to know how did you go to
immersion camp and not leave with a
heavy hoodie
yeah
yeah i kind of jammed that up that
opportunity real slippy over there yeah
i got a cool giga i got a good guitar so
yeah so did everybody that attended
mercy count you know
one of them
oregon usa yep all made in america
everything from the materials
themselves yep oh by the way there's a
bunch of people that have been trying to
get stuff from overseas and there's a
bunch of ships sitting off the coast of
california and new york and they can't
get their stuff in here their supply
chain is all jacked up guess what we got
an american supply chain an american
supply chain did i just say that the
whole thing
every single part of that
garment that you're wearing be it jeans
be it boots be the freaking rift gee
doesn't matter that whole supply chain
is right here in
america we're not waiting in the port
we're not we're not paying somebody to
have imposed slave labor to build you a
freaking pair of jeans and then call
them american
no that's not american how can a pair of
american genes not be made in america
answer me that riddle me that echo
charles it's a hard ritual you can't you
can't solve it because it's wrong it's a
lie i understand
we're not doing that nope origin usa dot
com boom also jaco is a store it's
called jocko store
i know nifty name i get it but some good
stuff on there discipline equals freedom
shirts hats hoodies jiu jitsu is live
jiu jitsu is like
i don't
i don't um
condone not doing jiu jitsu choosing not
to i'm not going to condone it right
but some people don't some people do
the people who do now they got a little
section
of representation on the path on the jiu
jitsu path is being
is emerging right now you know how many
people have told me that they've started
jiu jitsu because of the podcast
how many do you think i don't know i
don't know how many you know how many
people have come up to me and said hey i
started jiu jitsu because of the podcast
and i really regret it
zero that number is zero
if you are listening to the podcast if
you're a living human being go start
training jiu jitsu let's go start
training jujitsu start right now
yeah it is then you can stop then you
can shop this did you do sex yeah and
also think about
all the people that said oh yeah i
started jujitsu i wish i would have
started sooner 100 i'm one of those
people by the way i'm i am too yeah i
wish i was born on the mats of justice
yeah okay you know you're always excited
about your little designs yeah and you
say they're
you give these you try and explain
you say they're more creative or they're
more layers you just say weird stuff
about them you don't know how to
describe them your limited vocabulary
trips you up right there jammed you up
as you like to say
so i was at jocko live last night and i
see a guy's walking up to me and he's
got a shirt that looks freaking legit
it's got like a metallic tank
writing on the top and it says
discipline and then there's an actual
tank
with the barrel pointed at the at you as
you look at the shirt
and
as he gets closer it's a comic book
cover
and i'm on it some cartoon version of me
riding a tank
and it's a t-shirt so that's the first
one that i've said yeah well
you know kind of dope they're not the
first one that's
it's the most differentiated from your
standard
jocko store shirts it's the most
differentiated one yeah it was kind of a
curveball stylistically it was good
though yeah i think it landed very well
oh i did it says deathcore to the core
yes on the top
so i learned something new recently
somebody was talking about the shirt
locker
subscription
and i i know a
good amount of people they're like man
that'd be awesome that i just have too
many shirts i got and i'm like i get it
trust me i get it well recently
i heard a common friend of ours i'm not
i don't know put his name on blast in
the podcast but
he was like i have way too many shirts i
don't need it he's like but i do a shirt
locker just to support echo
and what he does is he gets all these
shirts he wears them for a little bit
and then he just gives them out as gifts
to people and people are like super
stoked about it
and so if you have if you're thinking if
you're like hey i have too many shirts i
don't need the shirt locker get the
sherlocker and just get your re-gift on
and this guy loves it he goes he gets so
much fulfillment out of just being able
to give out the shirts to different
people or someone's like hey i like that
shirt he'd be like cool and he gives it
to him
there you go there you go see the shirt
locker going to pay you twice i'm going
to pay you going to get a cool t-shirt
i'll pay you when you give it away to
your friend because i liked it
yeah i don't i mean it depends on your
lifestyle i don't feel like i have too
many t-shirts because of the shirt
locker because all of them that come in
are in the rotation granted i'm a little
bit biased because i probably won't make
one that i wouldn't wear
maybe i would hope i don't think so that
would be kind of whack yeah yeah that
doesn't make sense to do that yeah yeah
but you know how like you just you know
how some people don't anticipate oh yeah
or they get a lot of recommendations for
something and you'd be like
it's a good idea i don't know if i would
necessarily wear that but it's like hey
but hey the proof is in the pudding
everybody's saying this and it's
actually technically i got it i see i
see it now it is now you're just over
there at the whim of the people kind of
chasing the glory like oh everyone else
likes it so i'm just gonna do it that's
where we're at i just figured it out
i call it listening to my people that's
what i call it oh should i not listen to
him look at you maybe maybe i have all
the good ideas i have all the good ideas
i don't want to listen to nobody's gotta
you're a politician
so if there is a demand for venus
would you go v-neck route then
uh in the words of both of you guys by
the way uh if there was a demand signal
for v-necks then yeah i might consider
it sure
anyway shirtlocker is on jocklestore.com
hey if that's for you we have some
developments in that um section by the
way um so if you're a current member
we're gonna have uh some upgrades and
some updates for you any moment no
dogstore.com that's right subscribe to
this podcast wherever you subscribe to
podcast check out the unraveling podcast
with daryl cooper dc
grounded podcast warrior kid podcast i
got jocko live last night kids children
put me on the spot
i have one question for you mr willink
uh yeah what's up son how can i help you
when is the next warrior kid podcast
coming out because it's been 14 months
next question from a kid
hi uncle jake i'd like to ask you a
question oh what's your question young
man how can i help you
uh i was wondering when the next warrior
kid podcast is coming out
sure my
kids i'm sorry man
uh
also jocko underground.com if you want
to hear some alternative podcasts some
uh some alternative information
life advice by the way life advice q a
yeah hitting a lot of q a in there you
can go to jocklenderground.com now
here's what we've been talking about
why do we do that well because we don't
control the platforms we don't know what
the platforms are going to do the
platform's big tech
what do we okay well whatever
what could possibly i be doing that
would make someone say hey you know we
need to pull this guy out pull the reins
in on this jocko guy i don't know but i
got freaking straight up shadow bands
legit shadow guy yeah i was gonna text
you because on one of your po well the
video you know that we did yeah with the
travis mill and stuff yeah and you
posted it so i'm like oh yeah you know
it's fun to see people's reaction to
that kind of stuff and man it was
getting no traction
i was like bro this doesn't and then you
had that other one that you were kind of
posting like stuff right like um the
video of your screen yeah yeah the video
that someone sent me of my screen
not seeing me right yep
you got straight up shadow band shadow
band for what i i actually don't know i
actually am not 100 sure i have some
suspicions
i have some things that i think it could
be
um
yeah
i've spoken out about some situations
that are unfolding
on instagram uh on podcasts
on my podcast on other podcasts
and
[Music]
that's that's weird though right yeah
where someone it makes me so mad i was
in colorado
and i told you this right before the
monster i was there working with a
client
um
was out and about met this uh family
there's a lot of little kids and i
started talking to him i was like hey
you should check out my boss um he's got
these kids for uh he's got these books
for kids called the warrior kid and then
mom was like i'm a teacher this would be
a phenomenal and so that the the dad was
like well what's his name i'm a jocko
willing he's like okay it which it's
funny anytime i say your name if
somebody doesn't know you
it bothers me
what are you talking about you don't
know and then i have to be like oh okay
not yet everyone doesn't know him yet
but they will and so i was like hey let
me see your phone i was like you have
instagram i'm like open it up he's like
all right because i don't want to do
like hey look him up later but forget so
i now this is my default it's like hey
open up your phone okay
open up your instagram okay and i'm like
let me see it real quick i just take it
and i start typing in i'm like
what the heck he's like is that him i'm
like no that's a meme page about him he
goes he has a meme page about him i'm
like oh yeah
so he started going through he's like
there's a quote page too i'm like oh
yeah
i had to type your name fully for you to
show up and then i clicked on it and
then i immediately was like and i was
like hey you're following him now
because i followed you gave him back to
him the guy was like why would why is
that i'm like yeah like he's being
shadow banned it's crazy so he starts
like looking through all your stuff and
he's like why would he be shadowbound
i'm like because he speaks the truth
it's so freaking crazy it's crazy that
that's
that's a dangerous thing is to speak the
truth these days it is very disturbing
it is very very disturbing and to that
degree where they can where someone and
i'm totally just speculating but they'll
hear you say something that they didn't
like like
somewhere else and then be like let me
go to his instagram
and chat about it it really makes me
start to think about all the level of
inner connectivity between some of these
elements out there
and it's
because it is very strange now look
could it be like oh i was you know
someone mentioned me or something or
some fault and they got an algorithm
that runs and it's like oh yeah this guy
boom and he got and then they went like
yeah we shouldn't have we should have
done that now because apparently i think
i might be on shadow band right now
i think so i think yeah i'm not sure i
went on on sarah's phone and looked for
you and you popped right up okay but i
think she's following she follows him
yeah so
that's yeah
well hey because of all this what what
jp i was gonna say
it's just even more confirmation that
you know you're doing the right thing
we're doing the right thing
dogs don't bark at parked cars
true you know
so
because of this
we and we figured this out was it a year
ago we started jocko underground.com
because i knew we needed a contingency
plan in case things went sideways we
could get taken off of every platform
that could happen
and so if you want to support us go to
jockowunderground.com it's eight dollars
and 18 cents a month that allows us to
have this platform that if things go
sideways we will be standing by
in the underground to
do what we got to do
if you can't afford it it's all good we
still want you on the team email
assistance at jackhomeunderground.com
and for like a reward or an appreciation
we do another little podcast
and talk about some alternative subjects
and you know what you know what i'll do
is i'll i'll
on that i will do a a one about why i
think i got shadow band i'll give all
the details cause i
i'm pretty
confident i have
i i'm pretty sure i know why um
interesting
um throwing this out here i don't need
to sleep tonight we can do it tonight if
you want
two weeks ago
uh
youtube channel
subscribe to that
official yep it's official or whatever
you can see what jp looks like you can
see his jiu jitsu to his life t-shirt
you can see my t-shirt i only only wear
those same t-shirts yeah that's kind of
what i do
um
origin usa has a cool
youtube channel as well we have
psychological warfare i made a little
album
you can listen to it if you have a
moment of weakness you can overcome that
moment of weakness flip aside canvas
speaking of dakota meyer not only does
he have a distribution company
he also has flip side canvas you can
hang cool stuff on your wall
dakota meyer freaking
one of my heroes
got a bunch of books final spin jp jp
danelle come on jp what up what's up jp
danelle you read
you got on the plane and you read final
spin how'd that work out for you hobie
okay well this is what i love about you
people don't understand this a little
behind the scenes jp and i
we can both we we are both
we we can both we can both get emotional
at certain things yeah and
it's funny to watch each other get
emotional
and we make fun of each other for
getting emotional laugh at each other
literally i was at the last mustard i'm
i'm sitting backstage watching jt get
choked up
and i'm laughing and i'm just preparing
yeah and yeah he's just preparing so i'm
like okay
so anyways as soon as he he he gives
walked into it he's like yeah i read the
book on the plane and i saw the look on
his face i was like oh it hit him it hit
him because it's a rough book to read
emotionally yeah it's an emotional
roller coaster it's awesome so
we got the copy of the final spin
at the muster so we're leaving vegas
amanda amanda had the copy
i ordered 10 like when they first came
out um
and i knew so i had some coming and so i
i i stole it from her like i took a
picture put on instagram she's like give
me my book back i'm like let me read it
for a little bit she's like okay so i
started reading i was like oh my gosh
this is legit
she like takes the book back she she
finished she's reading on the flight um
then i'm gone for ftx's come back the
books are there i grab it and i read it
in two or three days i just i could not
put it down and
i didn't want to read it at night
because i knew like when i would read it
at night i was i was not going to sleep
because i was just like no one more trap
one more one more
and um today
you know flying out here i'm finishing
up my packing and i grab it and it
irritated me because i knew i was gonna
finish it before i took off
um
but i needed to finish the book but i
was like i want to finish it i'm just
carrying another book for a week on the
road again and i have my other book that
i'm going to be reading
um or finishing off but yeah it was
awesome like i was just like sitting
there and i'm
the very front of the plane everyone's
coming on board and i have tears rolling
down my face as i'm like reading the
book i'm like you got to be kidding me
now if anybody knows me well it's not a
surprise like you know i'm an emotional
person you know one of my real close
friends was one of my black or is one of
my black belts so matt waltman and he he
just knows he's like bro he's like i
know when you're gonna get emotional if
he listens to a podcast of mine he's
like yep and then i'll get emotional
just if you know me well you know that
i'm an emotional person and i he used to
bother me i don't care anymore because
i'm like well that's the way god
designed me yeah it's the way god
designed me
it's part of who i am but yeah final
spin that was awesome sitting on the
plane tears rolling down my face i'm
like you gotta be kidding me
because
i think
and i'd like to talk to more people
about it but i truly think
every human that reads that book will be
able to relate to all the characters i
don't care what your background is 100 i
don't care what your background is
you are gonna find a relationship to
every one of the characters everyone
like the store manager i wanted to beat
that guy up because i've had some of
those bosses in the past
artie
man that kid you know um
damn it
just just everything you know and just
what
the main character did for his brother
yeah it's just a phenomenal book i i
truly i would put a large amount of
money down and say if you read the book
you'll be able to relate to every one of
those characters and i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna give it away yeah read it
because it's ridiculous but i will say
like just that style
that the style that you wrote
like i'm looking forward to more books
in that and if not then
you're the biggest jerk ever put that
out there and then not have
more books coming down the pipeline jack
right on uh appreciate it that book is
called final spin it's an emotional
roller coaster
you don't even expect it really at some
points and all of a sudden you're like
wait wait why am i getting choked up
right now yeah so i wanted to say this
quote earlier and i didn't find the
right time but
i think it ties into this book like the
principle of the book you said this
at one of the last ftx's ftx002 that we
had in san diego
and i wrote it down and i know i i
shared at the muster part of my talk but
you said when you transition from loving
winning to loving your team winning more
than you winning yourself you transition
into a true leader
and that's sacrifice
if if
when you're willing to put the team
above yourself the mission above
yourself
that's when you become a true leader and
you you ask this question
and we ask it now at all the ftx's
what do you think makes a good team guy
and everybody all the answers are great
they're just not the right answer
it's when you put the team first and the
mission first that's what makes you a
good team guy and that's not just for
the seal teams
company xyz
when you and your employees put the team
first and the mission first that's what
makes you a good leader and you don't
have to have a title to be a leader
we've said this your title doesn't make
you a leader your ability to influence
those around you to do the right thing
to believe in themselves to believe in
the mission that's what makes you a
leader
and
i've i love this quote i've written it
in all my notebooks that i have just as
a reminder as well as
discipline as rooted in the truth that
we tell ourselves that you told me
and i just it reminds me i think that's
also why i got emotional reading that
book is because
he was willing to do what he did for his
brother
and that's what good leaders do
like they they are willing
to put
the team and the mission above himself
at all costs now
what he did in the book is obviously
part of the book to
but the base of that is he
it wasn't about him
it was not about him
and when we look at the good companies
that we work with the leaders that care
more about the team than themselves
i remember i called you i sat and had
dinner with denver
before we were in the ftx
and i he was sitting there and he was
emotional and
he was talking about how much he loves
and cares about his team
and it was real you know and we've
worked with companies where you knew
they were kind of full of it they're
trying to put on the game
i mean he he pulled out like index card
that he had notes on for our talk and
just
the the level of impact the training had
on him and how much he cared about his
team i remember i texted you and and
life afterwards and i called you because
just the burden of that and you're like
hey bro
you're gonna deliver the training that
he needs and that's all i was like check
roger that and
it just it's cool
just when you see
leaders
truly care
about their team and they put the
mission first what they're able to
accomplish
that's it man
um
final spin a lot of those themes in
there
one of my friends texted me and said
this is a
great piece of american literature
and i said thanks man appreciate it
that's a bold statement right bold
statement
final span
leadership strategy and tactics
field manual
the code the discipline the code the
evaluation the protocol display freedom
field manual
weigh the warrior kid one two three and
four best books ever
apparently that's what a lot of people
are thinking
adults children across the board
mikey and the dragons come on
come on
about face by hackworth extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership that i wrote with my brother
lee fabin we also have well we're
talking about sponsors today if you if
you're interested in the ftx or any of
the consultancy that we do go to
slamfront.com you can also find out
where we're doing the next muster which
is dallas texas march 24th and 25th
we also have an online training program
extreme ownership academy we are on
there all the time
we got courses that you can take we got
live interaction that you can do you can
come ask ask us questions there's so
much benefit it's a leadership gym you
don't get good at leadership by reading
one book it doesn't happen just like you
don't get good at jiu-jitsu by going to
one class you got to make it part of
your life go to extremeownership.com
to make leadership part of your life
and if you want to help service members
act and retire their families gold star
families check out mark lee's mom mama
lee she's got a charity organization she
is really helping out veterans
just giving them
treatments you've had those treatments
yeah
hyperbaric chamber
game changer it was an absolute game
changer my body was
in a medical
state that the doctors literally were
like we don't know what's going on i'll
tell you what's going on you're drinking
nine monsters a day for three years
yeah no more like 10 years straight but
it was i was having well i was having
kidney and adrenal gland failure and we
just
like when you're going to doctors and
they're like hey we don't know this this
is what we know is going on but we don't
know what to do we don't know how to
stop we don't know what's causing it
and then kobe hit and i hit up mama lee
because she was like hey you need to get
in these treatments for your tbis and
i'm like okay yeah because you know i
have
real bad tinnitus and um you know just
issues with just remembering stuff and
headaches and stuff like that and
problem sleeping and she's just been
trying to get me into the treatment now
i couldn't because i couldn't commit to
the treatments that i had to do because
of how busy we were well coveted hit and
i was able to do it and i did all the
treatments
all those issues were gone like they're
gone and they haven't come back and we i
have no other team guys that had masses
growing in their in their head pituitary
gland like
cancerous types of masses that they
didn't really know what was going on go
and get the treatments and they're gone
yeah like just it's incredible
what those treatments do and actually to
the point that
one of our clients at echelon front
that's a part of dave's ldap program
that we did in ftx for one of the guys
like hey what's a good charity that we
can donate to and i told them america's
mighty warriors this is what they're
doing
well one of these team members was so
motivated because i told them what
happened to me
other members like cowie who's on our
team like he went got those treatments
he said it's been a game-changer night
and day
um and
every everybody i've listened to it's
not just for team guys we're talking
just any service member that has
problems we're getting them in there
well this member of the client
that we that we work with ran up the
chain of command and now their company
is doing a thing to where they they pro
they produced trailers like heavy haul
trailers for the trucking industry
they designed a uh america's mighty
warrior trailer where it has the logo on
the trailer on the back everything and
they're donating i'm not gonna say the
amount but for every trailer they're
donating a large amount to the
foundation and their goal is
they want to be able to pay for i want
to say there's like five or seven
treatments through i mean
it's incredible
and she's only able to do this through
companies and individuals that donate
yeah it's it's it's insane if you ever
wonder what happens with money that you
donate to a charity and if it's
effective it this is 100 this is what's
happening medical treatments that are
that are game changers for veterans so
that is
america america's
mightywarriors.org this is mark lee's
mom mama lee
that's where you can go to help out with
that
um
if you want any more of my
tedious tirades
or you need any more of echo's perplexed
ponderings
or you want some more of jp's hyped up
hypothesis
it's accurate
and you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on the gram
facebook jp is jp dannell
echo is that equity charles i am at
jocko willing echo any closing thoughts
good to see jp in person again it's
always good to be here jp
anything to close it out
no i said what i wanted to say
right on
all right
well
speaking of military personnel to all
the military personnel out there around
the world
staring evil in the eyes in order to
keep us safe thank you for doing what
you do and to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics
emts dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service and all
first responders thank you for
protecting us from evil here at home
and everyone else out there remember
there's always more to learn there's
always new information to absorb you can
always hone your skills you can always
improve your technique you can always
increase your knowledge and you can
always
always get
better
well actually almost always because
if you close your mind
and your ego says that you already know
it at all well then guess what you won't
learn you won't improve and ultimately
you won't get better and you won't win
so put your ego in check go out there
keep learning keep getting better and
yes
keep getting after it
and until next time this is jp and echo
and jocko
out